I had no idea when I stood up what was
going to happen I literally thought like
when you talk about the testimony Brett
I mean I thought the
the science the review that we had done
was going to be warmly embraced like I
actually literally was trembling I felt
like Ivermectin would be deployed in
this systematic prevention and treatment
of covid worldwide and that things were
going to be different and better and um
and then my same thing that happened to
you I mean my career you know I lost
three jobs I'm out of academic medicine
my academic career is over and I also
have a new um a new livelihood and I'm
actually quite happy about it but the
transition was difficult but I didn't
know that was going to happen I didn't
volunteer for that
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the pleasure and honor of
sitting this morning with Dr Pierre
Corey who many of you will know from the
covid pandemic writ large and from Dark
Horse he made a previous appearance on
Dark Horse which was taking off like
wildfire before YouTube removed it and
struck our Channel
and in some sense Pierre I think is it
reasonable to say that
um that podcast allowed you and me to
mutually ruin each other's careers
oh that would be the understatement
Brett I think you're I was already in it
but you launched me like right onto the
front lines of the battlefield and you
know we've we've taken some hits and
suffered some casualties but we're still
standing yeah yeah we um I would say we
we have lived to fight another day uh an
achievement about which I am quite proud
me too and uh it has been an honor to
fight alongside you Pierre it's it's um
you have been one of the the very bright
spots in a very dark period of History
I I don't know it's a very moving
statement Brad because it's I know
you've been through a lot and in some
ways I feel like you almost got it worse
than I did I mean you you really
um
I don't know I think you were more well
known and so there's more people to
attack you and yeah it's it's been rough
but I wouldn't change it for the world
and I and I thank you for everything
you've done and and we've been we've
been just trying to do the right thing
that's all well I think I think we both
uh you know
took some heavy fire in our own domains
I almost not even almost I feel worse
for people like Paul Merrick who
um you know as a colleague of yours who
I didn't know until you pointed me in
his Direction but you know you clearly
have you are motivated by your anger at
what was done to to patients and to
Citizens during the pandemic and it
activates the fighter in you and you and
I are a little different in this way but
I have a similar reaction to it guys
like Paul Merrick I feel you know this
was a good doctor who he was not
supposed to be thrust onto the front
line of some uh battle in which he would
be accused of all kinds of vile things
right this was a guy who cared deeply
about his patience and he needed to be
left alone to take care of them
um so as bad as what happened to you and
me is I feel worse for people who didn't
train for it yeah you know I like kind
of you almost contrasted me and Paul and
I think it actually would be a fair con
like you know I fight with my fists and
he fights with his heart you know and he
he's really
you know he I think he has a lot of
sadness and I he has I think we have
both have a lot of anger but yeah I
think he's more
yeah sad and tender about it and I'm
just really angry
our first sponsor for this episode is
new to us it is better biome maker of
knobs nobs it's a new kind of toothpaste
and it's fantastic in fact we started
using this product several months ago
and approached them rather than the
other way around better biome that's
biome without the e on the end is a
brand that I first found and brought to
the rest of my family's attention now we
are all using their fantastic product
every day and can attest that they are
telling the truth when they say that
they are a brand focused on transparency
safety and effectiveness
let's talk fluoride for a moment
fluoride is of course the anti-cavity
ingredient in most toothpastes that you
already know about but as we discuss in
our book The fluoride that we encounter
is not in a molecular form that is found
in nature and it has never been a part
of our diet and Evermore research is
pointing to neurotoxicity from fluoride
exposure especially in children
knobs from better biome doesn't contain
fluoride but that in itself does not
make it unique many oral care products
are now abandoning fluoride as the
research continues to emerge about toxic
effects but unlike competitor products
knobs includes a different and far
better re-mineralizing agent knobs uses
hydroxyapatite
hydroxyapatite is the main component of
the enamel in your teeth and is in your
bones as well
it has been extensively studied in
medicine and dentistry and is as
effective as fluoride in remineralizing
teeth without the toxicity
hydroxyapatite doesn't just stop
cavities from forming it can even arrest
tooth decay once it is underway
furthermore even most natural
toothpastes that are free of fluoride
still have lots of abrasive ingredients
like charcoal baking soda eggshells
knobs has none of these things knobs
also contains no sulfates parabens
phthalates microplastics no BS it's
right there in the name
furthermore knobs comes in the form of
dehydrated tablets which allows them to
be shelf stable without any
preservatives take a tablet chew it and
then brush as you normally would your
teeth are going to feel fantastically
clean because they are
also unlike with toothpaste TSA has no
interest in knobs because they're
tablets so if you're flying with knobs
you don't risk losing it in security
so check out knobs at
www.betterbiome.com
Darkhorse remember buy them without the
e
b-e-t-t-e-r-b-i-o-m.com slash Darkhorse
listeners can enjoy 15 percent off their
first one month supply of knobs from now
until July 17 2023.
our second sponsor for this episode is
House of macadamias trees aren't edible
I speak from experience but tree nuts
are delicious and nutritious they are
generally high in fat and low in
carbohydrates and contrary to what
various food pyramids and government
agencies might have led you to believe
high fat low carb foods are increasingly
understood to be both satisfying and
good for you
each species of nut is different however
and for many of us macadamias are the
best nut there is
macadamia nuts take a very long time to
grow however and because they are both
rare and highly sought after they have
the dubious distinction of being the
world's most expensive nut
between the taste and health benefits
though they're worth it they have even
fewer carbohydrates than most other nuts
for instance half of what cashews or
pistachios have and two-thirds of what
almonds have which makes them the
perfect snack for breaking a daily fast
and controlling blood glucose they're
also uniquely rich in omega-7s including
especially palmatoleic acid and
unsaturated fat that has been linked to
Natural collagen production fat loss and
heart health
and House of macadamias is intent on
making this amazing food accessible to
everyone they have partnered with more
than 90 farmers in Africa and now make
one-of-a-kind vegan keto and paleo
snacks
these include their dark chocolate
dipped macadamias and a delicious
assortment of bars made with 45
macadamia nuts in flavors including
salted caramel and chocolate coconut but
our favorite product of theirs is the
simple salted macadamias made with
namibian sea salt they're amazing we
love them and we think you will too
House of macadamias also makes a
delicious macadamia nut oil which is 100
cold pressed rich in monounsaturated
fatty acids and has a higher smoke point
than Olive Oil so it's well suited to
high heat cooking and baking and they
have just introduced delicious nut
Butters you can imagine how good those
taste
our house of academia's Highly
recommends House of macadamias for all
your macadamic needs for a limited time
House of macadamias is offering
listeners a free box of their best
seller namibian sea salted macadamia
nuts worth 35 bucks with your purchase
at House of macadamias.com Darkhorse
plus twenty percent off your whole order
with the code Darkhorse once again
that's
www.houseofmacademias.com use Darkhorse
for 20 off your order you won't be sorry
our final sponsor for this episode is
Vivo barefoot shoes made for feet all
right unless you are driving or
operating heavy machinery I want you to
try this exercise look down at the ends
of your legs do you see feet okay then
this message is for you everybody should
try these shoes most shoes are made for
someone's idea of feet but not vivos
vivos are made by people with feet who
know how to use them and word is
spreading people often approach us
because of the vivos that we are wearing
saying they've heard they're good and
they are these shoes are every bit as
good as you have heard here at Darkhorse
we love them they are Beyond comfortable
tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain at all because there are
no pressure points forcing your feet
into odd positions they are fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to move
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by sixty percent in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them
vivoba Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and they have everyday wear they're also
a certified B Corp that is pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their Footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild upon
it
go to vivobarefoot.com and use the code
Darkhorse 15 to get an exclusive 15 off
your order additionally all new
customers get a 100 day free trial so
you can see if you love them as much as
we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the code
darkhorse15 at checkout
yeah really well I appreciate your anger
before we get going here let's just
frame this a little bit for people who
might be uh joining this discussion late
who maybe weren't there for the initial
Dark Horse episode and don't know what
we're talking about
you came to my attention
as the most prominent voice
I hate to use the word advocating
because advocacy is not the role of a
doctor nor of a scientist and it's it's
a term that's pointed at us frequently
but you were the leading advocate for
the idea that we had tools at our
disposal that we were not using during
the covid pandemic I saw a now quite
famous piece of testimony that you gave
a quite impassioned speech to the Senate
was it yeah yeah um about Ivermectin and
as you probably remember
Heather and I had our own trajectory
with uh Ivermectin where you know
initially we believed what we had been
told that this was a drug that maybe had
initially shown some promise but that
scientific study had proved it was
ineffective and then when we just
scratched the surface of that claim we
discovered all kinds of shenanigans and
there's a moment on Dark Horse where I
literally think what I said was what the
[__] is going on here right there was
too much [__] surrounding Ivermectin
to for this just to be the normal fog of
War somebody was monkeying with our
ability to even understand what it might
be useful for
at which point I found uh your testimony
and anyway uh the die was cast I suppose
yep
um but in terms of in terms of framing
the discussion
you obviously have a new book out about
the uh you want to show your book yeah
so I have it right here so it's called
Uh oddly or aptly the war on I ever Mack
them
um the subtitles the medicine that saved
millions and could have ended the
pandemic
excellent now
um you asked me to blurb your book which
I was thrilled to do and I think
actually that blurb might help people
understand why you know many people
have the sense like what does it matter
now and
it matters a great deal now that we
understand what happened to Ivermectin
even if the potential utility of it is
now greatly reduced by the endemism of
the virus could you read could you read
that blurb
yeah so um I just want to say how
honored I was that you wrote
um you know support for the book and
yours was one of the most moving so
here's what you wrote Brett
the covid-19 pandemic changed the world
among most profound changes was a coup
by public health bureaucrats against
doctors and the traditional practice of
Medicine
medical professionals and scientists
were told how to think and those who
bristled at the New Order or at the
broken logic it dispensed were ridiculed
censored and cast out
there was to be one and only one answer
to the pandemic a pair of unprecedented
barely tested Therapeutics portrayed to
the public a safe and effective vaccines
the only hitch in that plan was that
these novel Therapeutics couldn't
possibly get FDA approval fast enough
instead these brand new shots would need
to get emergency youth authorization
which because of the danger of
experimenting on the general public
required there'd be no available
alternative that requirement is why an
all-out War has been waged on Ivermectin
a drug that safely and effectively
treats and prevents covid but isn't
worth money because it's no longer under
patent if the truth of ivermectin were
ever recognized it would bring the full
criminality of global covet policy into
Stark relief the war in Ivermectin tells
this shocking story in Vivid detail from
the vantage point of Dr Pierre Corey a
heroic and highly decorated ICU
specialist who spent every minute
fighting on the front lines of this
dirty covert War waged by Pharma and its
governmental captives against doctors
patients and all the citizens of our
Earth
yeah
that does encapsulate the significance
of of your book of what happened
regarding Ivermectin and I would ask
anyone who is listening to this podcast
if you have not confronted the evidence
of malfeasance surrounding Ivermectin
please put aside what you think you know
because the the amount of money that was
obviously spent to create a false
impression
surrounding the utility of ivermectin
with respect to covet and it has two
different kinds of utility which we will
talk about but that vast sum that was
clearly spent and the tools that were
brought to bear to demonize anybody who
saw or even glimpsed the truth here
is
in many ways the the deepest layer of
what I think of as
um
kind of a red onion pill right it's not
a red pill covid is a red onion pill
because there is layer after layer and
the deepest layer involves
a an Unholy Alliance
between governmental functionaries
members of the press Tech platforms
to make
consideration of ivermectin unpalatable
and to portray those who somehow escaped
that Labyrinth uh appear like quacks I
mean including you a highly decorated
doctor and by far not the only one on
this side of the question
to portray you as lightweights or as Sam
Harris famously mused
possibly schizophrenic for your belief
that there might be some value to this
drug that um
that edifice that was created really
tells the tale of what has happened I
think to civilization right this was a
story that illustrates the reason that
we are losing the ability to govern
anything well
100 you know Brett you know you just
talked about that Unholy Alliance right
and you just listed right the
governmental entities uh the media
um the social media platforms
and you know I I want to add to that on
holy Alliance so really what that
Alliance is built on because this is
what's been exposed to me like I I think
the the deepest and most powerful lesson
that I've learned
is and I don't know how I'm going to say
this but it's the Deep rot at the core
of medical Sciences which is to say
really at the level of the clinical
trials and
um you know prior to covid
um I I had a general implicit faith and
trust in in the institutions of society
um Brad I'm sure you were much more
worldly than I was before in terms of
what the media you know the narratives
and the propaganda in the media but I
mean I believed in the New York Times
um I believed in the high impact
journals I thought the best science and
scientists published there like if you
got published in new general medicine
that was like yeah that's like the
Pinnacle of your career and I I thought
only the best studies made it and what I
discovered in covid and which is really
strange because this has been well
documented for decades right so you know
I always quote um Marcia Angel the
doctor Angel who who was the former
editor of the New England Journal of
Medicine for 20 years and you know she
stepped down in 2001 to write a book
about how farmer was literally running
the journals and I mean that's 20 years
ago by the way uh Brett they don't teach
that in medical school there's there's
no class in medical school which is
about the scope and the scale and the
influence of control of the
pharmaceutical industry of literally the
medical sciences and you know
that Unholy Alliance like all of that
you know and what my book is structured
around is it's really it's a case study
in how disinformation is practiced and
literally you know as defined
um according to the disinformation
Playbook right which was really invented
by the tobacco industry and it's and
these are tactics they use to counter
science that's inconvenient to their
interests and they've been you know all
Industries practice this information and
they all use the same Playbook and it's
using that Alliance right they control
agencies and media and now social media
I would say what is unprecedented Brett
is
um you know when I look at the history
of media and propaganda I mean it's been
going on for a couple hundred years I
mean there has been huge you know
newspaper Barons who owned you know you
know multitudes of papers and so there
was always control over narrative but
now
the ownership right of media is so
Consolidated and concentrated I can't
remember the the exact step but it's
like I think five or six companies own
almost all media at least mass media and
um you know but the media in order the
media and the agencies to do what they
did they needed the science to support
that Narrative of the horse dewormer
ineffective and I just want to finish
this point on that is that you know I
have a chapter in the book called The
Big Six
and the reason why I called the big six
is because it was literally six trials
that were unique
okay so they were unique in terms of the
fact that they were large heavily funded
done by highly I wouldn't even say
respected but you know very accomplished
researchers
um but they were the only six out of for
instance all of the early treatment
trials they were the only six where
literally every investigator on that
trial was drowning in conflicts of
interest with the pharmaceutical
industry and they were heralded as the
top as like the answer to all answers
right these were the most rigorous high
quality randomized controlled trials and
each of those six were published in high
impact journals and they were the only
trials that generated massive media
campaigns right every time they were
published Front Page New York Times LA
Times Boston Globe all around the world
Ivermectin found to be ineffective
and and so I I guess my point is that on
a holy Alliance is founded upon
the the the the the science the little
conduct of science they manipulated
trials both ways that they can create
trials designed to show something
doesn't work they can manipulate trials
to show that it works and safety and
efficacy and all that we and we saw so
much it wasn't just Iron Man right I
mean we saw with hydroxylchlorically we
saw with the vaccines I mean they just
they're literally control science and so
whatever they conclude in those high
impact journals is what everybody
believes and
that that was astonishing to me bro I I
you know listen I I'm an old liberal
right and I I you know big Pharma was
always a four-letter word right no one
ever trusted big Pharma right I mean
their history is profoundly uh actually
Criminal
but what I didn't know you know I always
thought they were manipulating things at
the edges they might hide a few things
that you know that was inconvenient to
them I I didn't know that they were on
the game like literally run the whole
game
yeah so you uh you mentioned the
question of whether I might have uh been
a little more worldly I think I probably
was but only because I went through
a different ringer 20 years ago with the
work I did as a graduate student on what
I thought was a purely abstract
evolutionary question with I didn't
realize that I was stumbling into a
realm that had uh medical and therefore
monetary implications and
having seen what took place there
whatever uh naivete I might have had
lots of people who are familiar with the
podcast will have heard this story
before but the short answer is
what I discovered was that there was a
flaw in the model animals specifically
myosin rats that we were using to do the
all of the early testing you know a lot
of the scientific work and the early
safety testing for drugs and that the
flaw in question which I believe arose
uh accidentally
but it biases these animals in the
direction of being extremely resistant
to damage that is to say they can repair
almost any level of damage that doesn't
outright kill them and so if you give
them a very toxic drug that destroys
cells it may actually cause these
animals to live longer because it
interrupts the cancers that they are
preternaturally prone to now I don't
know I don't think Pharma understood
that until I put it together but I then
there's a story about the attempt to
prevent my work from getting published
but I did ultimately publish it
I pointed directly to the implication
for drug safety and that was 20 years
ago literally as far as I can tell the
only thing that has happened is a lot of
backroom double dealing in which the
pretense that there's no problem or that
if there was a problem it has been
solved without any discussion of how
that was done right that has been sort
of uh spackled over this giant Hazard
and because the flaw in question
a seems to be likely explanatory for
things like the viox debacle
similar cases with uh fenfen Gleevec
erythromycin all of the NSAIDs
because it seems to be explanatory of
something in which human beings are
injured and killed
and because there was no interest what I
thought as a young graduate student 20
years ago was that even if
they're
was something broken about our system
that would not have been eager to take
care of this problem that the
embarrassment of not taking care of it
would have been so profound that it
would have been forced to address it
directly and when I saw Zero movement
and when I attempted to raise this issue
in the Press
and it was like a bell that didn't ring
right it was like a dream where there's
a bell and you're trying to ring the
bell and you hit it and there's not a
sound
that experience told me there's
something
the physics of the universe that I am
now in do not add up right and I believe
that what happened is Pharma realized oh
we've got mice that bias safety tests
into making drugs look like less toxic
than they are
well you'd have to be crazy to fix that
that's why I think we're still stuck
with it but anyway that did
um
let's just say raise my awareness about
the possibility of very major things
being wrong let me ask you a question
about that Brett because I you know you
it's intriguing so
basically what you learned with your
inconvenient science is that they have
the capacity to suppress and or ignore
right or just basically somehow make
that not known
did they did they actually do any
studies that conflicted with yours
because that's the other thing right all
they need to do is inject doubt right so
they can do a study showing that you're
wrong right they can find the opposite
conclusion to what you concluded and
that that's kind of what I see them as
the most effective way of of neutering
inconvenient science
well I think a couple things are true as
is always the case these things have a
conspiratorial component
you know the Jax lab the place that is
the source for the vast majority of the
mice used in scientific experiments and
Drug safety testing
has somebody since my work was done who
is nominally in charge of mouse
telomeres right but one gets
gobbledygook when one tries to chase
down what that actually means are they
monitoring is there some record of the
length of the telomeres in the colonies
you know can we look at what the current
state is
and one does not get a straight answer
so at some level there has to have been
a meeting or meetings in which they
decided a strategy to uh not upend their
business not have to redo all of that
safety testing on the other hand there's
an awful lot of
emergent Behavior among scientists and
others who know which side their bread
is buttered on that looks like a
conspiracy but doesn't it didn't
function like one so for example
if you know in what way the mice are
misleading
that gives you a mechanism to predict
the outcome of experiments that would
otherwise be unpredictable if you can
predict the outcome of experiments
before you run them then you can look
like a genius and you can publish
important papers in the New England
Journal of Medicine or wherever else
because you look like you're just
excellent at science where instead what
it really is is you know where the
bodies are buried and how to interpret
the bias yeah so anyway a lot of people
I believe
the Cutthroat world of Medical Science
once they realize what's going on do
they want to kill their careers by
trying to call it or do they want to
ride that wave and those people may
never have been brought in on any
conspiratorial conversation they're just
getting ahead yep
um so no I I don't want to detract from
a discussion that should be about your
book and about the war against
Ivermectin but
the one thing I did want to say is
you're talking about
the degree to which Pharma yes not only
influences but has effectively fully
captured journals medical schools
medical associations
governmental Regulators all of the
pieces of the puzzle necessary to create
a totally fictional world yes which is
what they tried to do during covid yes
and so I call this the Pharma game and
they and I think part of what people
don't get is
yeah you know 20 years ago we all knew
Pharma was a problem right and like you
we all believed oh it's probably
altering the science enough to matter
yeah not writing it at a whole cloth
right exactly
um so we're looking what we're really
looking at is
The evolutionary product of the world we
all thought we lived in right Pharma
having too much influence over
Regulators instead of it is The
Regulators it is effectively the
puppeteer
and it is moving these puppets around to
create the impression that science is
being done to ensure the safety of the
public it's not true 100
impression creates the impression
absolutely creates the and it's worse
than nothing right because the thing is
if you didn't have regulators
right if all you had was your doctor
and a bunch of pills your doctor would
be in a position to notice and to
discuss with other doctors hey I don't
think that pill is safe maybe stay away
from that one but the impression that is
created through the journals and through
this phony scientific work
um actually causes I'm sure it causes
doctors to override their doubts about
safety right how could it not maybe I'm
seeing you know maybe the pattern I'm
seeing isn't really a pattern maybe it's
sampling error and I know that because
hey here's a large study that seems to
suggest exactly the opposite well that's
exactly it right I mean the doctors you
know when I think about medicine I mean
not really my career but if you look at
the history of medicine like you know
some of the seminal books from the
subject I mean the pharmacopee at that
time the amount of medicines that we're
using in disease I mean it was very
small right now you have huge amount of
medicines right all coming through
Pharma funded trials and all that and
your your point is is correct I mean the
average doctor you know they essentially
they have an implicit faith and trust
into that those institutions right the
journals and
and the the the people who do the
studies and they think that there's an
Integrity there's a Code of Ethics
there's you know all of these things
and they'll believe what they're told
and what's shocking to me Brett is how
much
they so easily believed that was break
you know so like one thing let's say you
talk about Ivermectin hydroxycorkum we
know that doctors are too busy they
don't really read studies critically
um they'll read the abstract first of
all even to read studies critically I
mean you really have to say like what
didn't they put in this paper like what
is missing like there's so much things
that you find out when you really think
about a paper and you know all these
anomalies like they'll present certain
data in certain papers and leave it out
of others you have to ask it why they
leave it out you know and so but doctors
they read abstracts and you know and
especially an abstract from the top a
medical journal in the world I mean that
abstract is thus truth right it's almost
like one of the you know the Ten
Commandments from The Mountaintop right
and and
and how much they just
you know like I guess I use the example
of like for me
like this unveiling right of the scope
and the scale of this capture and
control you know was slow I mean it was
slow and iterative during covet I mean I
was learning these I was finding these
astonishing and really disturbing facts
of these things that they were just
divorcing themselves from even pragmatic
science or even you know these were
policies divorced from science and I was
like how can they do this how are they
getting away with this and I will tell
you the the day that I remember being
really the most upset and Disturbed was
the day that the FDA put on their
website that there's no evidence to
support checking antibodies before
vaccination you know when when the
vaccines came out like my my good
friends and colleagues like who were
internists who had offices right their
patients were coming to them for
guidance around the vaccine and I mean I
mean their initial gut reaction was like
taking history did you have coven right
that would be one way or check
antibodies and so like one of my
colleagues he was checking antibodies
and if he had a positive antibody you
can skip the vaccine but here we had you
know a governmental agency telling the
entire country of doctors
that this thing called natural immunity
which we've which is as an evolutionary
biologist Brad I think you can speak
about natural immunity more than most I
mean this is literally how we've
survived right uh through history and
viruses and you know organisms and
suddenly
some words on a website and the entire
country just goes with it without
critical questioning without a
discussion I mean there was some stuff
around that but like how did they cancel
or disappear natural immunity with one
page of a website
people just recovered Brad I mean you
know I I the worst story I've heard not
the worst I I don't want to qualify like
that but I had a patient uh once about a
year ago she was a a pharmacist who
worked at a hospital and she told me
that the hospitalists at that hospital
were vaccinating covid patients upon
discharge
wow and yeah that to me was a wow moment
I said wait a second you know because
there is a some precedent to that like
with flu like people come in for some
other reason during the flu seasons and
you know the doctors will offer them a
flu shot because they're captive right
there it's like hey you're here we'll
give you a flu shot so flu shots kind of
you know it's like kind of a checklist
upon discharge so like I get that but
here you had patients admitted for covid
survived covid
still probably a little rocky not all of
them are well but they're ready to go
home and you're going to vaccinate them
with an old protein that was the other
thing it was like late 2021 so guys
we're using a two-year-old protein and
anyway your your answer that when you
said wow that that was what I said that
day I just I literally was like what is
going on the world has gone mad well
it's
incredibly foolish for multiple
independent reasons
right on the one hand
and and I guess the the thing that's
really frightening about this is anybody
who's gone through medical school
ought to be able to piece one if not
both of these together
one
the history of vaccine safety is not a
clean record until 2020. there are lots
of cases where vaccines that were
promising did not get through safety
trials because they were dangerous and
there are cases in which vaccines that
were released were withdrawn because
they turned out not to be safe right so
the idea that vaccines are safe is Dead
on Arrival that is not a true idea right
if vaccines are safe it's because we're
good at the safety process
in this case you had so-called vaccines
that were a highly novel in their
mechanism of action really unprecedented
and B the safety testing at best was
truncated by time and there is no way to
accelerate safety testing because part
of what you're looking for are long-term
effects and so there is no way to know
that there wasn't something lurking five
years out
right so a doctor
should be interested in taking anybody
off the list of candidates that they can
take off without a cost even if these
vaccines were highly effective and there
were no harms that had been spotted you
should still want to vaccinate as few
people as you have to
because the potential of hurting
somebody in some way that we didn't yet
understand was something you couldn't
take off the map so natural immunity
that should be like oh what a relief we
don't have to take any risk with you
because you got through it your immunity
is going to be better than this vaccine
which provides one antigen it's not
broad it's it's almost stupidly narrow
it's an old antigen right from a variant
that is no longer circulating so thank
goodness we can take you off the list
and not expose you to that risk every
doctor should have seen that and then on
the other side the part that's maybe
harder to spot
is
you're dealing with a layered set of
complex systems
what happens when you take somebody who
has just recovered from the current
circulating version of a disease and you
inoculate them with something that
triggers the production of a closely
related antigen while their immune
system has not fully stood down from the
infection it just beat right does that
make them more susceptible in the future
does it make them less does it cause the
immune system to think that it has
failed to fight off the infection and to
go into some kind of overdrive that we
don't understand there are a dozen ways
I could go wrong it's super complex and
and then the related uh question which
we've explored a little bit is what do
you what happens when you give someone a
vaccine for that narrow old antigen
which is now quite different right it's
mutating it's not the right and we know
a little bit about that with flu because
they've always done you know they're
always a day late and a dollar short
with the flu vaccine but this was
this is even more I think it's even more
mutagenic than the flu I mean this thing
was rapidly changing rapidly changing I
think in part or in large part because
of the vaccination campaign itself which
creates an almost absurdly concentrated
evolutionary pressure which drives the
virus around
um but in any case the obvious caution
that should attend medicine when
confronting a novel therapy
right
was simply not there the desire it was
like a religious desire to vaccinate
people rather than a hey we've got no
choice we've got to do a lot of
vaccination but let's figure out who
doesn't need it right
you know you Brett I mean you're making
the way you lay that out right just
makes so much sense it's pragmatic it's
prudent those are all principles that
you would think a doctor would employ a
physician would employ and let's be fair
though Brett you know what you're the
reason that you just articulated
this there's a percentage of doctors who
did approach and I think thought of it
that way some very tiny numbers stood
firm and stuck to those principles
but if you look at the the
population physicians in this country
I think there's a large percentage who
just believed what they were told that
they didn't have critical thinking but
the one that's most troubling is that
percentage and I don't know what
percentage that is who knew this was
wrong
and were coerced and co- they realized
they couldn't put up resistance if if
you did you were going to be shunned and
vilified and even unemployed right I
mean if if you were in your office and
you worked for an employer and you
started telling patients come you don't
need the vaccine you don't need the
vaccine I mean you're not around long
and those who thought it was the right
thing because all the the fouchies and
the experts and all the societies were
telling you to vaccinate everyone so you
thought you were doing you know the best
science I think there's a lot of
Physicians who literally thought like
because the expert said so
it's the right thing to do
um the best scientists and the best
Minds in the country in medicine are
telling us to vaccinate anything that
moves
um so let's do it but there was a
proportion I think that thought like you
bred and and they went along anyway
that's true
um for the purpose of understanding the
Ivermectin story I would just
simply within the confines of this
conversation I would like to give them a
temporary pass
for reasons I think will become clear to
you in a second okay
it is hard and this has been hard for me
as somebody who
got ejected from his career and was
forced to start another and then had
that one uh interrupted by YouTube in
part because of the party podcast
[Laughter]
that YouTube decided uh to to move
against our Channel
um but as somebody who is faced who has
been driven now from one mechanism to
another for earning a living and keeping
a roof over my family's head I have a
hard time judging people that I don't
know and whose circumstances I don't
understand for responding in
disappointing ways to intense pressure
in their professional realm I want them
all to stand up but I understand that
most people
um
aren't built for it and I also know that
some people
you know what would I do to save my own
children yeah I know some people face
that and that's that's totally a fair
State and you're right I mean not that I
should be more forgiving but more
understanding in a way and I get that I
mean
you know yeah it's it's not easy it's
not easy and here's the thing though
Brad like the things that you did and
you stood up for
when you did them though you didn't know
what the consequence like I didn't know
what was about to happen because here's
the example like you know when I meet
people especially in the the bubbles and
circles that I travel in now I mean
generally I meet supporters right people
who understand they follow our science
they believe in our guidance and you
know people will say things to me like
you know thank you for standing up your
courage they'll use words like hero
and I'm like uh the actual truth is I
had no idea when I stood up what was
going to happen I literally thought like
when you talk about the testimony Brett
I mean I thought the
the science the review that we had done
was going to be warmly embraced like I
actually literally was trembling I
thought like Ivermectin would be
deployed in this systematic prevention
and treatment of covid worldwide and
that things were going to be different
and better and um
and then my same thing that happened to
you I mean my career you know I lost
three jobs I'm out of academic medicine
my academic career is over and I also
have a new um a new livelihood and I'm
actually quite happy about it but the
transition was difficult but I didn't
know that was going to happen I didn't
volunteer for that right had I known
would I have done it differently I'd
like to say there's no way I would have
done it differently I would have done
the same thing but I I really didn't
know and and when you talk about these
other doctors that I was kind of like
being quite critical to
you know I do think they're in a
different position because they know
fully well what the what those
consequences are right because they've
seen what happened to their colleagues
who stood up or stood out and and so
yeah I think that's a different calculus
than well no I'm gonna stop you I know
you're trying to agree with me and I'm
going to disagree with you because I'm
not saying they shouldn't have stood up
and you're right I didn't know what was
going to happen to me there was no
guarantee and frankly I want to live in
a world where people do what you did I
want to live in a world where people did
what I did and in such a world we'd be
better off right what we face now as a
collective action problem where people
who keep their head down do better and
people who stick their head up are
punished and that is a world that
belongs to Pharma so I'm not intending
to make some kind of
excuse for people I'm just saying I'm
hesitant to judge people especially if I
don't know their circumstances and for
this conversation I just want to
acknowledge that not everybody maybe
they all should but not everybody has
what it takes to stand up in the face of
what you and I both know firsthand was
an insane level of coercion and pressure
and the reason that I want to grant them
that temporary uh exemption here
from what I think is their moral
responsibility
actually I will just go back and say we
are talking about violations of the
Hippocratic oath and the Nuremberg code
so this exemption doesn't get you very
far right those things those are sacred
principles for good reason
but
the
um the reason to Grant a formal pass is
this
it surprises me but it is true that
people have are more awake to what took
place with respect to the so-called
vaccines than they are to what took
place with
um repurposed drugs and I would also
tack on Vitamin D yep it was barely
mentioned during the pandemic and should
have been front and center
so people get that something happened to
them with respect to the vaccines people
get that something caused their doctor
to ignore their natural immunity cause
their doctor to ignore the innate
immunity of their children
that something wanted them vaccinated in
spite of the fact that nobody could have
known these things were safe and in fact
on closer inspection they knew they
weren't right so the fact that people
are awake a bit on the so-called vaccine
question to me should have them say now
wait a minute
if I can see how far the reality was on
the so-called vaccine question only a
couple years out
right the distance between the narrative
that we were sold and the reality we can
now see
then I know
that there is something massive
distorting perception in this area and
my question really with respect to many
people who have
gotten pretty good on the vaccine
question
but still can't see what happened to
Ivermectin is why are you so damn sure
of yourselves shouldn't what happened on
the vaccines cause you to throw out
everything you think you know and start
over analyzing right if you think
randomized controlled trials prove that
Ivermectin is ineffective against covid
are you willing to look at what was
inside of those trials because it's
shocking right this is the same story as
the vaccines
so
you know that's been
that's been one of the that that is a
really quick a really great question
right so yes in in people's Awakening or
awareness now of of what happened around
the vaccines and the manipulations and
suppression of the data the coercion and
clearly that there was an incentive to
have those things successful right so
you know why aren't those lessons
applied to like you said other areas of
science I think it's a very natural
thing so so the other thing I think is
like literally the mirror image of the
vaccines was repurposed drugs and and
I'm just going to call someone out as as
the most shining example of what we're
talking about this inability to see past
the vaccines is is really Alex barenson
um I think he is the most glaring
example and you know I've had the
opportunity to talk with Alex like we
were on Steve kersh's podcast where
Steve was really excited he wanted us to
have a debate and you know we tried to
get Steve to come now we're just going
to have a discussion and it was a very
professional discussion I was very
polite and I was you know I was trying
to teach Alex I was like Alex
you're you know and I and I I commended
him Brett I said listen Alex your work
on the early calling out of all the
anomalies and invariances and and all of
the really the fraud from the trials and
to the suppression of data and the
misrepresentations of the efficacy of I
said your work has been great and I
think he's made a big really positive
impact by getting people to be really
cautious and questioning these vaccines
and yet he comes out and he holds up
those big six trials which are just
reeking of Fraud and conflict and he
holds them out as like the Pinnacle of
Science and he goes on Joe Rogan he says
I ever imagine is no better than a
placebo and I and I talked to I said
Alex I don't understand
why you don't see that for the vaccines
to be successful those that wanted
successful it was required that they
destroy the science around repurposed
like it's not a complicated concept but
I mean that lesson that you just gave as
an example of the vaccine that lesson
should guide us in question all of those
things and the incentives to destroy
repurposed drugs were the same incentive
supporting the vaccines and they use the
same taxes just one they wanted to you
know the narrative that they want to
create is that it's safe and effective
and the other one is that it's an
ineffective horse dewormer but they were
there were two hands of the same body
yeah it it it just makes no sense to me
right as soon as you discover
that a wobble in a planet's orbit
implies some other gravitational body
right now the point is okay
what else does that explain
and the the desire to Short Stop the uh
you know it's like the scales fell
halfway from their eyes right like that
doesn't make any sense look at worst
let's say Ivermectin was a fiction had
no relevance to covet which one should
not expect for multiple reasons if you
once you actually understand
that this is a drug that is actually uh
surprisingly broadly useful against RNA
viruses
you know the the presumption should go
the other way but nonetheless let's say
that it was a total fiction
at worst you throw out what you think
you know you go back to the the evidence
and you arrive back where you were
because the evidence holds up like what
have you what have you lost you've you
know in fact you're on a much more
secure footing having thrown it out and
arrived at the same conclusion twice
whereas if you actually do this exercise
and you say well what would have to be
true
for these trials
to be wildly misleading about the
utility of this particular drug well
they would have to be
either
built to fail in some subtle way or they
would have to report evidence in a
misleading fashion that it created a
false impression of no efficacy
actually both of these things are in
there right they're right there to be
found now the fact that it took
incredibly smart people
weeks to unpack what actually the
methods meant in order to figure out how
the trials were built to fail right
that's a story in itself no method
section should be so complex that it
takes a group of people you know
weeks to unpack what was actually done
the method section should be
straightforward yeah but you know let's
take for example the
um
bizarre and as far as I know as yet
completely unexplained
BMI cut off
for the increasing dosage of ivermectin
Ivermectin is a drug that is dosed based
on body weight and of course covet is a
disease in which the hazard of the
disease goes up spectacularly with
excess body weight and so in order for
you know so basically people who are
thin are at much less risk and so you
would expect a drug like Ivermectin to
be much less useful because they're not
going to get sick 100 and so you would
expect if this was a highly effective
drug you would see it in people who were
obese
and what do you find in the methods very
subtly you see the methods if you read
them uncarefully they have a decent
accelerating dose that goes up with BMI
yeah but cryptically there's a cut off
at which for no reason they stop
increasing the dose which means it's
specifically under doses the patients
who are likely to be sickest and
therefore creates the impression that
the drug is not effective
Brett that that point you made like for
someone like you or me you know when I
see that like I don't even spend like I
know exactly what they're doing right I
mean there is no rational explanation so
never before right so Ivermectin right
it's used uh for decades giving her out
across continents right to to rid the
world of parasitic diseases it also
happens to be an antiviral as we know
but you know in the Decades of use never
has anyone heard of a weight limit to
docent you dose it per kilogram body
weight period And it distributes to the
fatty tissues you have more fat you need
a higher dose right
and suddenly in these trials in covid
and I like how you say like I don't
think it's even that subtle what I find
is when you read the methods it's just
simply stated it's it's not like you
know they give you their rationale right
they just say you know this struggle in
the intervention group it was drugged
according to this schedule and uh anyone
above let's say 85 kilograms 95
kilograms
um received that top dose and then it
just stated there as if that's normal so
a casual reader will just read and say
okay they they had a upper weight limit
to dosing I'm sure it was because of
safety right safety Brett is that is
that what it was you know that but
that's what someone would presume that
there's no nefariousness there when I
saw it I was like what is this weight
limit and then you have to ask yourself
then why would they put a weight limit
if it's an extremely safe drug it
dosed according to weight why would they
do it and there's only one answer to
that right which is what you said is
that it's a brilliant way of mitigating
or trying to disappear the efficacy
because it's it's going to be strongest
in the obese the highest risk is where
you're going to see the biggest benefits
and
it it's not that subtle Brett but I
don't think it's not that subtle I mean
again you know your point about uh
doctors reading abstracts this is
scientists too and it's an expected
effect of the competitive nature of
these disciplines
right people are trying to get the
biggest bang for their buck and there's
diminishing returns in reading the
details of the papers so people
economize and it's wrong because the
bodies are buried elsewhere you know
um you know a a mentor of mine uh used
to joke he would say may all your
abstracts come true right you know our
their own uh their own species yep um
but in this case especially you know and
Alex Berenson
How could somebody who understands as
much on the vaccine side be as easily
duped as he's been on the repurposed
drug side
right it's just not that hard right if
you go look and you know frankly the
work has been done right we now do have
a very good description of exactly how
these trials were built to self-sabotage
and then I mean the irony of ironies
here of course I'm not telling you
anything you don't know is that you've
got Pharma which is expert in making
trials that make drugs look better and
safer than they are and expert it turns
out in making drugs look less effective
and less safe than they are
and it sets up trials to fail designed
to fail and the drug is good enough that
they don't actually fail the advocacy is
still reflected in these trials if you
look at the data if you look at the
presentation it's quite different and so
you know how much of this do you have to
see before you have the equivalent of my
what the [__] is going on moment yeah as
soon as you see that it's like well I
can't tell you what the truth of it is
but I can certainly tell you I don't
trust this paper
I mean that that point you just made
right which is you know I
and I'd like to laugh at some things all
those it's just this Topic's not funny
but you know they're expert at
manipulating trials I mean they they
design trials with predetermined results
and that's described in the
disinformation Playbook I mean tobacco
did it I mean they've been doing that
for decades but you know with Ivermectin
I found it fascinating because here you
have
the top guys who know how to do this
right Farmers literally writing these
protocols for them they put every little
trick in the book to try to better the
efficacy and Ivermectin was so good they
had a lot of trouble disappearing that
signal Brad you know that they had the
resort to stuff
that you know you normally don't see
them have to resort to and I I think my
favorite not my favorite I don't want to
see Fair my the most potent and Brazen
example was the NIH active six trial
where they had to do something which is
considered a never event which is
changing the primary outcome in the
middle of the trial
and they changed it right they were
looking at a difference in illness I
think symptoms severity
um at day 14. that was the original
protocol which makes sense for violin
unless you want to see who gets better
by day 14. and in the middle of the
trial without providing any data for why
they did it they switch it to now we
want to compare how people are feeling
at day 28. and in the actual paper you
see that at day 14 there's a profoundly
statistically significant difference in
favor of ivermectin so if you're a trial
is there and you're you know Farmers
running these agencies in these trials
suddenly your researchers are telling
you uh Houston we got a problem here we
have a profoundly statistically
significant benefit that we've
identified at day 14.
what are we going to do
the answer
let's change the endpoint to day 28
where that statistically significant by
the way it's still beneficial there just
wasn't statistically significant yeah it
wasn't statistically significant which
somehow you know because the Press is
undereducated with respect to science
yep uh journalists will translate into
no effect which is absolutely and
completely unjustified interpretation
um but
you know I I have been
persuaded by my own scientific Journey
that the philosophy of Science Matters
tremendously and almost nobody is
educated in it because it's boring and
seems like a different field and all of
that and this is a case where
the
alteration the moving of the goal posts
in the middle of the study is
it renders the entire exercise
completely scientifically invalid
invalid Brad if I did that in a try
let's say I did a study imagine the the
the the speed of the rejection from the
journal when I actually submit my paper
and they say they see that I changed my
endpoint moved the goal post in the
middle of conducting a study they would
say I'm sorry we can't publish this
you've you've committed a scientific you
know a trial a trial wrong like these
these invalidate I'm sorry Dr Corey this
invalidates whatever you found so the
level of evidence it invalidates it at
the level of behavior it's fraud yep
right you are
the thing that makes science work
is the directionality of the observation
right you have a pattern
You observe it you hypothesize a
possible explanation you formulate a
test based on the predictions and then
you run the test it has to go in that
order or there's no science in it
if you knowingly take the prediction and
you modify it to match the data you have
taken something that is anti-scientific
and you has Dre you have dressed it as
if it was science which is not only is
there no information in your study
because we don't know where else you did
that but the intent
evident in your modifying you're moving
the goal posts mid-study
is to deceive to lead people to believe
that the evidence says one thing rather
than what it actually said right you are
required even if you think your study uh
found sampling error right to the extent
that you are interested in publishing
this study you have to publish what it
actually found relative to the actual
predictions which in this case come in
the form of this particular measure That
Was Then altered mid-study
that's fraud you describe the scientific
method right and you talked about then
tested and here there's some rules on
how you test things right you come up
with a study design and you say I'm
going to compare these two things in
this way
and that's what you got to stick to
right but here here I want to go a
little further right so you you call
that out first of all it's anti-science
it invalidates the study I like how you
call that the behavior is fraud right
the ACT is anti-science and invalidating
the behavior is fraud but let's go
further there that study
sailed to publication in the Journal of
the American Medical Association which
is literally I think it's number two or
number three on the highest impact
medical journals in the world
published that study
where they move where they change the
end point in the middle I mean and there
was really very little mention of it
it's not even a limitation and of course
no one talks about in the media no one's
like oh Jama just published a study but
they moved the goal post in the middle
and and what's even more crazy right and
I I'm sure you've seen the table right
because Alex Mourinho did such good work
on on dissecting these trials I mean his
work is unparalleled um in the stuff
that he's done and he's not even a
physician I'm using polymath he's
brilliant but I mean I I would the
comprehensiveness and detail of the work
that he did I mean I learned a lot about
I learned way more Shenanigans in these
trials than even I could pick up I've
heard Alex right and but you know Alex
you know highlighted the table that's
published in the actual so it's so
Brazen where they show the difference at
day seven day 14 and day 28 and you can
see the statistical City you see that it
was highly statistical significant Days
Seven day 14 and then whoops just falls
under statistical seven day twenty so
it's screaming from the paper
in the journal American Medical
Association there's no discussion of it
and so that that's gonna that that to me
would be like exhibit a in a courtroom
of evidence that Pharma runs these
journals
a hundred percent and I would just point
out like let's say
all right
you've recovered from covid
and you go to the doctor and the doctor
says all right let's get you vaccinated
right so let's suppose you know what it
means that you've recovered from covet
and you realize hey Doc how much do you
know about the safety of these novel
vaccines and what happened to natural
immunity we know that that's the best
immunity what's more if I look at these
vaccines there's no way it could
possibly compete because the antigenic
choice is so narrow and the antigen is
uh of a variant that's no longer
circulating so you you hear okay your
doctor is advising you to get a shot
that can't possibly be safe
and cannot possibly compete with the
immunity that you've already got and the
same doctor is telling you
um yeah if you get covid uh or you're
exposed to somebody who has it
Ivermectin doesn't work at the point
that you discover that your doctor is
in some way Downstream of some
Distortion that has caused them not to
look out for your best interests with
respect to these so-called vaccines at
the point you know that they're
needlessly exposing you to the risks of
a novel therapy
when that same doctor tells you that
actually repurposed drugs are not
effective
then you should wonder whether the very
same distorting influence has caused
them to miscall that one as well and
what I see almost across the board
is people assuming that the embarrassing
Revelations surrounding the so-called
vaccine campaign are the limit of what
happened for some reason the
sophisticated position is yes but
Ivermectin didn't work
which uh is obviously not like that was
the ceiling of the corruption and fraud
was the vaccines right and they they
don't see how much further and deeper it
went right
um and I don't I don't think they
understand
well I mean this is really the core
issue yeah
um they do not understand
what the pandemic would have looked like
if
we had played differently with respect
to repurposed drugs and vitamin D
right if we had applied those things
um what would you know look through
pharma's eyes yeah at the level of how
profitable this would have been it was
spectacularly profitable profitable as
it went down how profitable would it
have been if we went on a campaign to
correct people's vitamin D deficiencies
and had applied Ivermectin as a
prophylactic when people were exposed to
covid and then treated them with
iramectin and hydroxychloroquine if they
came down with covid what would the
pandemic have looked I feel like I to
raise my hand be like call on me I want
to answer that you know all right
I mean Brett we know the answer right it
would have obliterated those massive
marketplaces that opened up with this
pandemic I mean overnight you had a
Marketplace in north of 100 billion
dollars right uh for the pricey patented
Pharmaceuticals and the vaccines and
first we'll obliterate that market that
that's one thing that's that was what
they were trying to avoid but we know it
would have changed the face of the
pandemic I mean we've seen it in places
that that use repurposed drugs I mean it
was a very that you didn't have
hospitals filling you would have very
few hospitalizations very few deaths uh
very little morbidity it would have it
would have changed the entire experience
of this pandemic and it would have saved
millions of lives and I want to say
something about vitamin D because you
brought it up and because I think it's
relevant
um to
it's highly relevant to me in my book so
you know what because there's an
anecdote that I talk about in a book and
I think you may have heard this before
but you know what happened after my
testimony you know here I am thinking
I'm bringing forth this news to the
world that's going to be warmly embraced
and you know everything goes sideways
real quick and I couldn't figure out
what was going on Brad
um you know within two days of my
testimony the Associated Press calls for
an interview I mean me and the team are
so excited we're like yes the Associated
Press is going to bring forth this news
to the world
and you know what happened I mean it was
a complete hit job you know I spent 20
minutes of my life that I'll never get
back explaining to this reporter
providing all of the data all of the
evidence and then what gets published is
this attack on my they don't even
discuss that they just lump it in with
another medicine to be debunked like
hydroxychloroquine like it was bizarre
like they don't even talk about okay so
this hit job happens and everything
continues to go sideways for months and
you know I knew that there was big hands
of farmer was everywhere I knew we were
you know we were fighting probably some
corruption but it was only in March of
2021 when I received an email and I
received an email from a guy named
Professor William B Grant and he's one
of the top published researchers on
vitamin D in the world spent you know
decades studying vitamin D and
Publishing on on its impacts and he
wrote me this two-line email he said
dear Dr Corey
what they're doing to Ivermectin they've
been doing to vitamin D for decades and
then he put a link to the article which
kind of you know structured the book it
was called The disinformation Playbook
and it's written by the union for
concerned scientists and I clicked the
link
and the article is really well written
it's very simple it's this graphics and
they just outline the tactics that
Pharma does to bury science that's
inconvenient and I'm looking at and the
tactics are named after football plays
you know it's the fix the fake the
Diversion the screen and they give
examples of each play and how how it
comes about and I read it and it was
like
like a light bulb would like to just
click suddenly bred like in an instant
everything I've experienced in the prior
three months you know the retraction of
my paper after passing peer review like
that we knew we knew that we we were
like that's Bill Gates I mean we just
knew that yeah
or Pharma I mean when when our when my
paper got retracted after passing
rigorous three rounds of peer review and
then suddenly that is like nope we're
retracting um you know we knew the the
fix was in but
you know the the disinformation Playbook
article was much more broad it showed
you all of the tactics that they use and
I when I'm looking at the plays I'm like
I saw that today they're doing that to
us you know this week that happened
three times last week and like I just
saw everything mates it's like having
the teacher's Edition to what was going
on in Cove I felt like I
and and from that point on from that day
on I saw the world through a very
different Looking Glass and I I just
could see everything and by the way
those tactics and what they do that's
not just Ivermectin right or even
medicine it's like it goes into many
other topics that are in the news and so
and so anyways I wanted to bring up
vitamin D because not only was it this
research around vitamin D but like let's
talk about that like so what I've
learned about vitamin D science since
then
is that like and I learned it because I
saw an article I think it was in Forbes
or in Time Magazine you know the
headline was like stop with the vitamin
D already that was the headline and it
was this long article basically
reviewing all of the summary analysis of
What vitamin D has been tested against
many many different diseases and
illnesses in cancer and this article
basically said that is in in these
meta-analyzes when you combine all the
studies of Vitamin D it essentially
doesn't work for anything
but the reality is
the literate the published literature on
vitamin D is so heavily polluted with
manipulated trials that they've
essentially been able to cancel cancel
the efficacy of vitamin they've been
doing that for decades I mean there's a
massive body of literature which
concludes
that it doesn't work right because for
every positive trial they will create
one to show it doesn't work and so all
you need to do is inject out or neuter
or have conflicting evidence and then
everyone can determine but in the end it
doesn't work and
and you know that vitamin D thing you
know I remember thinking the beginning
like we need a national campaign we need
Billboards out there go to your doctor
check your vitamin D level put it you
know you we needed printed protocols for
how much to supplement in the newspapers
right I mean
any rational Public Health official
would have done that
and
even if there were any doubt about how
well it works right and I don't think
there could be any reasonable doubt but
even if there were doubt
it's effectively harmless up through
some incredibly high dose and so the
point is you know
if it was a placebo
fine you could make an error but the the
evidence that it was profoundly useful
is overwhelming if you know how to look
at evidence and I would also point out
the implication of the story you just
described that there is a vast sea of
phony literature designed to create
doubt about the efficacy of vitamin D
if you just simply evaluate that and
find out that it's true that you have a
lot of studies that seem to cast out on
vitamin D and that those studies are
built to fail for example
then the implication
is that Pharma in a general way because
vitamin D is so General in its
implication
is willing to make the population sicker
because it sells remedies 100 right and
that is a very troubling fact and really
you know I think everybody who's
listening ought to ask themselves this
question that's a very provocative
statement that Pharma might be willing
to make the population generally sicker
because it creates remedies and the
answer is that's a challenge right if
you found that that was not true then it
would cast doubt on your and my ability
to understand evidence and to recognize
patterns of bad science and if it is
true then it casts doubt on all of the
things that you think you know because
studies tell you that that because you
don't know how far the influence goes
dad I want to talk about that Brett
because that's literally what happened
to me like intellectually
philosophically morally like you know I
I feel estranged from medicine now and
from many Physicians I I you know
you know when you think about how long
they've been and the way you the way you
characterize it right so you're
literally putting forth this notion
which is really disturbing to
contemplate which is that
you have an industry that is in the
business of corrupting medical evidence
so that you don't take something that
can protect your health because they
want you to develop more illness so that
they can make money they need more
customers right that's the simple way of
saying it I mean you put everyone on a
good dose of vitamin D you are going to
shrink your customer base
and for numerous diseases
and so you have an industry that's
capable of working directly you know
violating public health and the health
of our community in our society and that
they've been doing this for decades and
then you have to also ask yourself the
question Brad is what else have they
done this with so if you wanna believe
what I'm saying about vitamin D then
you're going to ask what else have they
destroyed on on over these decades and I
mean vitamins are one thing right
they've destroyed vitamin C and vitamin
E and a and
you know but lots of therapies have been
destroyed like that and so then you're
left with the unfortunate realization
that the modern practice of medicine is
highly curated around you know a
discrete set of quite profitable
interventions things that don't make
money or that protect Health you know
are not going to be taught and they're
not going to be disseminated and so the
last thing I want to say on that Brett
because it kind of it refers to what you
were saying earlier about
you know realizing you know if you've
suspected that something wasn't right
around the vaccines and you've gone
further and you know you listen like the
example the example of that doctor you
gave you know who's telling you to take
the vaccine even though you got over
coveted and then he's saying don't take
those medicines because they're
ineffective horse dewormers and you know
like wow this distorting influence has
now kind of captured my doctor and my
doctor's not making sense I I want to
say what what how I see that now so
where I go Brett you know the places I'm
asked to speak and lecture or
conferences that I go to a lot of them
in the medical Freedom Movement
um the people who come up to me are
nothing short of terrified of going to
their doctor many of them have abandoned
their Primary Care practitioners that
they've seen for even a decade or two
because they'll go into the office he's
wearing a white coat and he's not making
sense he's not making sense and he's
telling them things that they know will
directly threaten if not maim them or
their health and and so how do you go to
someone who you've always sought counsel
to who suddenly doesn't make sense and
is giving you advice that is directly
contrary to your interest and your
welfare
yes this
I have been I feel like I've been on a
lonely quest to make a particular point
and I think there's something about the
terminology that is just it's an
unfamiliar thought pattern and so I have
trouble getting people to see it but the
point is
medicine and public health are not
synonymous nope
right and Public Health
is predicated on
something true which is that there is a
population
level set of questions surrounding
health
right that if you optimize for
individual health
you may end up with results that at the
population level uh are sub-optimal
right with respect to for example
um
epidemiology and Immunology right the
ability to get a large enough percentage
of the population
inoculated with a good vaccine that
prevents a communicable disease you do
not want people
um necessarily optimizing
away small risks to their own personal
health If it creates a large number of
cases that didn't need to be right now I
have become skeptical that any
governmental Authority can be trusted to
adjust the difference between individual
health and population Level Health in an
honorable way and I think we all have a
sacred right to protect our individual
health especially in a landscape with as
much obvious capture as there is in ours
but nonetheless analytically
there is a question to be answered about
what we can do at the population level
that is worth doing to improve health
over the largest number of people
however
what happened during covid
as I said in that blurb to your book
was it coup by public health authorities
and in my opinion deeply corrupt Public
Health authorities that were not
interested or were delusional about what
would maximize Health across the
population
a coup against doctors who practice an
ancient art on its best days medicine as
a science but on an average day it's an
art in which people who are expert in
looking at ill health
uh deploy a limited set of tools and
advice
to increase the well-being Health and
Longevity of their patients
sounds good to me
what happened during covid was that
doctors were effectively forbidden to do
that they were forbidden to develop
their own understanding of how this
disease progressed who was at most risk
they were forbidden to deploy what they
knew about the hazards of unknown
Therapeutics right they were told what
to think and they were threatened if
they departed from yes and that coup
has not been reversed right the pandemic
may be over at least formally declared
to be so
but the Damage Done to the power of
doctors the Damage Done to their
credibility and the Damage Done to their
right to do what they trained to do is
ghastly yeah and it leaves those of us
who need doctors which is frankly pretty
much everybody at some point
in a very bad position I experienced
this fear I don't I don't want to go to
a doctor who I know recently allowed
themselves to become a puppet of Pharma
and I don't know you know they literally
couldn't tell me if they had realized
that they had been making terrible
mistakes for three years
and they're over it how exactly are they
going to convey that yeah yeah
I I mean you you've summarized the issue
and I mean it's
you know that the fact that we we do
need doctors we're all going to need a
doctor and you know those that are free
from that oppression and coercion and
control you know we still at least have
a private practice system in this
country and they're you know I like what
Peter McCullough has said you know I
think he once said that you know
literally those that were saved from
covid who are treated with these
repurposed drugs he estimated I don't
know where he came up with this number
but he basically said it's the community
physicians that were in private practice
not working for Health Systems he thinks
there's about 500 of them uh and and
literally treated many hundreds of
thousands of patients
um and but that's there's not enough
there to serve the needs of our society
and so you're still left with a medical
system with a history because because
that's the other thing Brad so let's say
people realized what their doctor became
in covid right which is used to term a
puppet of the pharmaceutical industry
well then you have to ask
how long have they been a puppet of the
pharmaceutical industry on on how many
disease models and around how many
medicines and then that's where I was
trying to tell you before like
what I'm learning now Brett's arm in
private practice I have a Telehealth
um practice and we I specialize in the
treatment of vaccine injury and and long
covet which are very similar conditions
and you know I I take fees I accept fees
I don't accept insurance I'm literally I
have that autonomy that's required and I
will tell you given the complexity of
these syndromes and this disease you
know I have to employ a whole range of
different Therapeutics and one of the
cool things about that Brad is I'm
learning so much I feel like I'm
I am retraining in medicine but now I
have this really rich network of
colleagues that I collaborate with that
come from different disciplines not
allopathic medicine I have some
brilliant osteopaths and chiropractors
and naturopaths and even homeopaths and
I'm learning about all of these
different therapies that three years ago
if someone had said to use like for
instance something as simple as
hyperbaric oxygen I would have been like
that's nonsense you know people claim
that it worse but
so I'm I have I I'm actually able to
deploy a number of different therapeutic
approaches that no one would have ever
taught me if I was still in the system
and
but really to break free from being that
puppet not only does medical education
have to change it has to be much broader
um than allopathic curriculum is allow
for
um but you're not going to get that if
you go I mean medical schools in this
country are literally controlled by the
same entities we're talking about right
so but I'm just saying there is let's
try to maybe put that as a positive
thing although there's not enough folks
like me and and others
um to meet the needs of society but I
think that is the solution we do need we
gotta free we got that we have to
re-gain that autonomy that freedom for
critical thinking using risk benefit and
alternative you know analyzes to the
decisions and what we guide patients to
do rather than literally being coerced
to following a protocol that's
applicable to everybody you know like
there is and then that's the thing the
complexity and the difference of
patience their risks and the coma you
know medicine is a real can be really
intellectually challenging that's
actually what makes it fun I mean I love
thinking through cases and problems and
and you know so when you talk about that
puppet or that coercion you know I do
like to mention that prior to covet I
had never in my career been told I
couldn't do something I couldn't use it
like basically you know prior to cover
Brett the risk was on you as a physician
your malpractice so if you did something
stupid if you did something crazy that
didn't have good evidence for it or had
some risks that were unacceptable right
that's on you right so you know you do
something wrong by a patient
um you're going to Bear the
responsibility
but here not only the responsibility was
relieved but so is the autonomy right so
they just told you what you do and then
then they held you um they didn't hold
you liable for it right because you were
following the guidelines and so well
it's it's worse than that though
because
okay they told you the advice that you
had to deliver and the Therapeutics that
were allowed and they forbid you to
prescribe off label and they interrupted
the ability to prescribe off label at
the pharmacy if need be right but the
now that I hear you describe it from the
doctor's perspective the echo of the
Milgram experiment is glaring because
what I also maybe this is what you were
getting at and I'm just slow to catch up
but the doctor who's been told what
they're allowed to prescribe and been
told they have no choice but to defend
to dispense this advice to dispense
disinterpretation right
that doctor
is
absolved also of
the horrifying experience of injuring or
killing a patient through an accident
through a misperscription drug
interaction whatever the point is if
you've been told what to do if you've
just become a medical Cog who's
dispensing Anthony fauci's wisdom about
how we're going to address this thing
and somebody dies
I think you would you know what choice
did you have you dispense the advice the
patient died that wasn't you didn't
choose the advice you were right so in
accord with the best available science
and knowledge and recommendations from
authorities I mean what could be more
impede unimpeachable than that right
you're doing the best science out there
and so you're right and then that is
that you you know there's a little
Nuance you brought up there because
you know we know that these vaccines are
incredibly toxic and lethal and so there
are Physicians who
by doing that
they they know that they've had patient
I've talked to Physicians who know that
the vaccine was the approximate cost of
death in their patients and
yes you're right it does so I'm going to
dissolve them like they don't have they
don't have to carry that guilt of having
made an error in judgment because they
by definition were using the best
judgment available or supposedly I guess
they were they were something was
packaged in that way
um but allow me to redirect us here a
little bit I'm getting something from
from your description
I'm like relearning a lesson I knew but
I'm seeing it from a different spot
there's a there's a principle I'm fond
of posiwid the purpose of a system is
what it does right it's the flip side of
an evolutionary principle that I don't
think has been
well laid out but basically
the creatures you get
describe the niches that are there right
if a niche is there it's going to get
filled by selection
and whatever Pharma started out as
there's an obvious Niche that it has
evolved to it has mastered right and the
Mitch the niche is how to
create demand for products
right demand for pharmacist products are
very rarely generated by health
demand is generated by ill health and so
you know I would expect in a world where
Pharma
had gained undue influence over our
scientific Viewpoint that prevention
would fall by the wayside
I would expect that
um the contribution of a very well
thought out diet
would fall to the Wayside in favor of
um advice that actually renders
vulnerabilities and um
A friend of mine has recently been
beating the drum in some uh
offline conversations about the
possibility that the advice we've all
gotten about the danger of iron
deficiency is actually flipped on its
head
um
I would expect Pharma not to be in favor
of
um
life habits that generate happiness
satisfaction
Etc and in thinking about this okay I've
described a kind of a dystopian World in
which this thing has evolved to
interrupt these processes that make
people need less pharmaceutical drugs
on the other hand when I think back
through the pandemic
you know there was a moment at which I
realized
this isn't just wrong advice
it's the inverse of right advice exactly
and in my mind when I think about this I
I think about the images of
signs closing off
Trails outdoor Trails because of the
pandemic
sand poured into skate parks where
children might have done something that
would have occupied them and made them
feel good and gotten them in the Sun and
right just the idea that if it was good
for you something opposed it right what
it wanted you to do was go inside where
you wouldn't make enough vitamin D or
you'd be confined with anybody else who
had the virus it didn't want you to
treat until you got really sick at which
point viral diseases aren't treatable
right right it gave you every piece of
bad advice in the book
and
it demonized anybody who noticed
right
that does sound like a
well here's the thing in evolutionary
biology we would draw a distinction
between a parasite you might say Pharma
has evolved into a parasite that is
draining Health from the system for its
own purposes but then there's another
term
a parasitoid a parasitoid is a parasite
that kills you I was going to say a
predator I was going to use the term
Predator it's more than that because
they are there is death that's resulting
a lot of death that's resulting and
what I'm wondering you know look one has
to be careful with thoughts like this
because you have to figure out how to
falsify it but I have watched science
come apart yeah right biological science
is no healthier than what you've seen in
medicine
why is that well you can't very well
have
do-gooders over in science Testing
[__] marketing claims and
discovering that they're not true and
discovering that what you really
probably ought to do is go to the skate
park or take a hike and definitely get
some sun and maybe sunscreen is
something you want to use very sparingly
yep right you can't have people doing
that and so you more or less have to
um neuter
the capacity of science to prove that
you're lying
and that describes what has happened
inside of the University system right
the puppets who are dressed as doctors
inside of medicine are dressed as
scientists inside the R1 universities
and it is a lethal danger to
civilization yeah I don't know how much
of its Pharma but it's clearly a kind of
spreading corruption but they were the
system that you just described right
that you would imagine it would be
constructed with these features I mean
you're literally describing the system
we're living in right and yep and then
you consider the amount of people who
are employed in that system who might
not recognize the system in the way that
you just described it and you know one
point I wanted to make this is going to
be like the
another third rail of a topic but you
know when you talk about that system
that has literally an incentive to
create a population that is ill right
and to make sure that all of the things
that can make you well and healthy and
happy
um are not as what is advised you know I
I
you know from what I've you know what I
learned about the covid vaccines not
only I learned about Reaper but it also
led me to studying childhood vaccines
and
when you look at the history and the
science that supports those vaccines you
learn some really really uncomfortable
facts
and I would say one of the most glaring
is the wealth of data showing the
absolute explosion in chronic illness
that's coincident with the explosion in
the childhood vaccine schedule
and so that to me is one of the of all
of the things that we've already kind of
talked about Brett I mean the things
that I'm learning when I say that I'm
estranged I'm lost I don't you know
because everything that I thought to be
true or at least
had faith in that was operating you know
with principles that I hold dear you
find that that's not the case and it's
very disorienting
um and then to find what you think has
been settled science which is this the
you know the overwhelming benefit of
childhood vaccines you find that that's
actually that's got some pretty flimsy
data to support and it has very
disturbing data that's suppressed
and then but the point that I wanted to
make is that we have so much chronic
disease in this country at rates that
you didn't see in the 70s and 60s I mean
there's numerous reasons right our diets
have gotten worse and uh things like
that but the the the
the fit the mechanisms of those vaccines
and what's in them and how they really
do
that we've shown how they can cause
chronic diseases autism and ADHD and all
sorts of things I know this is a
troubling topic for people because you
know how much can you bring someone
along like I've come along slowly here
but but I keep discovering this system
at work
so this is a this is a very important it
is an uncomfortable topic you know
um
but let's take a different version of it
okay
I came to an understanding that
something about the Iram actin story
didn't add up at all
and I said so and Heather had spotted it
we followed that road we discovered what
you and I have been talking about
I was very
late to apply what I had learned about
Ivermectin and the Distortion field
surrounding it
to hydroxychloroquine hmm right so were
we we were too a little bit yeah it's
funny I just and you know at the point
that I got to that
right at the point that something woke
me up that I needed to actually refigure
what I had thought about it because
everything I had learned about
Ivermectin meant that I didn't know
anything actual about hydroxychloroquine
and then of course it takes nothing to
discover that what happened to
hydroxychloroquine was purely political
right
um
it was identical but I I you know I've
made the statement Brett that um you
know I wrote the book The War on
Ivermectin but there's another you could
write the war on hydroxychloroquine I
mean it could be the same book in the
state same same tactics same Playbook
you're right there was some more
political there was a there was a
political Dimension because of trump
right right um political Dimension
because of trump and you tell me if I've
got it wrong but I think uh
maybe just because Ivermectin is
so unusually non-toxic right
they didn't kill people with it well you
reported the point that I just wanted to
make and I'm glad you made the point is
that you know when you look so going
back to what we were discussing earlier
about some of these manipulations in the
trials and you look at how they designed
Ivermectin trials to fail
their main tactics so they used about
four or five and I'll just list them so
one we already talked about right which
is this ridiculous unprecedented
unprecedented dosing limit right to
these patients so as soon as you hit a
certain weight you're not getting any
more over magnets so under dosing you
know the highest risk the other is
obviously treating as late into the
disease as possible so they would enroll
patients up to 14 days after first
symptoms which I can't say without
laughing
um they use the lowest dose possible
that they could get away with for the
shortest duration
um you know no trial of iverm actin you
know for a long time ever used five day
I've never heard of an antivirus there's
no antiviral out there that's ever used
for less than five days and so it's the
lowest dose starting late mildest
patients uh you know capping the dosing
limit
um and then obviously fat what's that
you forgot fat I mean uh uh
and taking on an empty stomach is that
what you're gonna say or or yeah that
this this drug because the typical use
of it is for parasites where you want
the drug active in the gut right yep in
such a circumstance
um taking it on an empty stomach might
make sense but if what you want to do is
have it be absorbed you want to do
exactly the opposite it it's fat soluble
and you need you need therefore to take
it with something that has fat in it and
they took great care to always tell
people in those in the big six trials to
take it on an empty stomach um and then
and then they did a phenomenal job of
making sure that the control group had
abundant access to Ivermectin so it's a
lot of these trials you know I I kind of
uh I'd laugh and say you know it's
pretty hard to prove that Ivermectin is
better than Ivermectin right and they do
that right
um but another another egregious
violation of uh the philosophy of
science
has access but they you know they pulled
those same um the same six tactics over
and over and over again and but but to
the topic right so I've long made that
contrast so the tactics they used to
prove that Ivermectin didn't work was
everything was about lowering lowering
lowering shortest duration lowest dose
empty stomach right
because there was a phenomenal dose
response to Ivermectin which is actually
one of the pillars to support the
efficacy of a medicine if you're saying
it's the thing that makes you know that
it's not a statistical enough exactly as
you increase those they get better
faster viral clearance is fast you know
and so we saw so we knew there was a
dose response and then the other thing
about Ivermectin which is the point you
were going to make is that it's really
hard to take a toxic dose I mean first
of all in a massive review done by a
French toxicologist he came to the
collusion after reviewing the entire
literature Viber method that no one has
actually ever died uh from Ivermectin
you know no proven case was actually
ever
um he felt provided credible evidence
that Ivan rectum was the cause of death
now there have been massive accidental
overdoses hundred thousand times normal
dose people do get sick but it's
self-limited they go to the hospital
they're a little bit neurologic toxic
you know confused disoriented and
they've all recovered
hydroxychloroquine on the and does have
an offer limit and what do you know
Brett in that system that you described
what do you know how did they do that
big trial of hydroxyl and they literally
used one of the highest doses sub-lethal
that you knew was going to make these
patients toxic and they showed that
people who got hydroxychloroquine did
worse
yep they couldn't do that with Ivory if
they tried that and people would have
gotten better so fast
yeah so I I think that's interesting
that these two drugs would have resulted
in a different you know Pharma had to
play a different game with
hydroxychloroquine but nonetheless the
point is it took me a long time my point
is that it took me a long time to go
back and rethink hydroxychloroquine for
no obvious reason it just didn't occur
to me that I was harboring something
that felt like it was based on evidence
that actually once I knew what had
happened to the so-called evidence in
the Ivermectin case of course I should
have gone back immediately
um but I think a lot of people are stuck
in that state where they know something
was wrong here but they haven't gone
back and said well then wait a minute
where do I need a fresh sheet of paper
you know so Brett like you said um that
you surprised yourself I think in that
what you learned about iverm acting you
didn't kind of immediately apply and
scrutinize hydroxychlorine which those
lessons should have taught you to ask
those questions of hydroxychloricate and
the same thing happened to us
you know I would say with Paul and I and
hydroxychloroquine in the beginning
we both put a lot of value in the
randomized control trials published in
the high impact journals which all
concluded that it was ineffective
and we put a lot of weight on those
trials for a while like Paul would not
recommend hydroxychloroquine I I came
around a little sooner than Paul because
I
I actually this is a great I would love
to have a discussion on the differences
between observational control trials or
randomized control trials but they're
highly valid observational controlled
trials I mean yes you do have to be
careful on how you interpret them but as
a body of evidence they're equal in in
their accuracy to randomize control
trials and when you saw the the breadth
of Trials of hydroxychloroquine and the
summary analyzes of them they all
pointed to efficacy and I was impressed
with the total body of evidence Paul put
a little bit more or he held on to
putting a little bit more value on the
high impact Journal randomized
controlled trials and he held that out
as you know and I think that dissuaded
him from recommending it but you know it
took us a little while after I've met
and realized that they pulled the same
stuff with hydroxychloroquine and and I
will tell you you know what you know
what I think finally turned us and Paul
was actually chapter one of Bobby
Kennedy's Book where he moves it out I
mean he tells you know that first
chapter I mean he tells the story of
what happened to hydroxychloroquine and
and
and when we read you know Paul became
fully convinced then that we'd been we'd
been lied to about hydroxycle and we had
we believe those lies for longer than we
should have and you know Harvey risch
and Peter McCullough and you know a lot
of the folks around the world who knew
hydroxychloroquine was working you know
I think they they were disappointed in
us that we hadn't that it took us a
while to get behind hydroxychloroquine
and um you know and and I've apologized
to them I said I'm sorry we were so slow
to figure that out and you know but that
had really big implications I mean that
that's also a massive loss of life
around burying the efficacy of that drug
and in fact I think that created more
harm than I've mentioned because it was
earlier from actin was not really a
strong candidate early on
some people you know there were a few
who knew that was a strong candidate
people like Robert Malone knew Robert
had done you know years with him his
wife Consulting around
um identifying repurposed drug
candidates for for different pandemics
and Ebola and
he they in in some of their through
throughput sequencing they'd identified
either from acting as um number one I
think against Ebola
um and so he knew a lot about repurposed
drugs and he he knew all this stuff
um but yeah but no but I guess my point
was that hydroxychloroquine had that
been deployed systematically in the
prevention and treatment as it should
have been from early on that would have
really saved the most lives because it
was 2020 it was right at the outset we
had something that worked right at the
outset and
you know something in which we already
had the manufacturing capacity to
produce it in large quantities
yeah it's
um so at at one level you have to look
at this and try to extract The Meta
lessons yeah something
that
I still find it bizarre how comfortable
it apparently is
uh depriving people of life-saving
information and drugs
something decided to derail
the right path for reasons that we can
get back to in a second
but
there's also something about the lesson
the
sociological lesson here
you are finding yourself
retraining in medicine
ironically because you're now
freed from the very subtle
controlling forces that exist inside the
institutional structure of medicine yep
I've had the same experience
in
science where I find my
colleagues inside the system are
constrained by things they don't even
see in terms of what the bounds of
responsible thought are and once you
leave the system it becomes clear how
much nonsense is circulating
um and so
you know the irony is
we've got these
big hospitals full of everything you
would need to practice medicine and
these big beautiful medical schools that
are perfectly set up to train doctors to
think scientifically and to treat their
patients and because this has all been
captured and corrupted by Pharma or
whatever other force and I you know it's
at least Pharma maybe it's something
beyond that too
all of these structures
don't work they're actually
counterproductive and
you have this odd fact you know the
people that you named you know
McCullough and Malone and you and
Merrick and uh cariati and you know we
could go on and on coal all of these
people have been cast out portrayed as
incompetent and they're the only people
that you can actually
trust to give you an honest evaluation
of the medical wisdom of something or
the medical meaning of some pattern
because they've already paid the price
right yep you have to stare down the
accusations and then yes it does
terrible things to you but at the point
that it's done the Terrible Things it's
said you know literally uh gee I wonder
if Pierre Corey might be schizophrenic
if that could explain why he thinks
Ivermectin works right once the system
starts deploying that kind of outrageous
slander against you
then you are actually free to look at
the quality of the studies to look at
the quality of the products to look at
the likelihood of these things improving
Health to look at the
um the
obvious remedies that are sitting right
in front of us that carry almost no risk
and have huge potential upside like
vitamin D yeah and you can just simply
say what is apparently true now it's
interesting that you you kind of you
that you had this you have the same
experience right you had to leave a
system of Science and I use the same
term you use I call them system docs you
know the patients who come to my clinic
the Leading Edge clinic by the way which
is what we called it
um you know all of them have journeyed
through the system and they've seen all
the doctors and in particular around
vaccine injury and long-haul covet
um
you know you're right the doctors in
that system they don't understand the
constraints they don't understand how
much information is being deprived of
the the they're actively not being
taught things there are so many things
they don't know
they don't know the question all the
things that I now question right going
back to that concept we talked about
like now having had the experience of
these three years
now not only did you say that I'm freed
up to do all these different things but
I'm also I've been trained now to ask
questions at a level
that I didn't know was that necessary I
had a lot more trust and now I have so
little and all I have is you can use the
term skepticism or questions and and the
the amount of questions of where the
answers are disturbing so like the
history of ssris
and statins
any number of things that are literally
pillars of allopathic medicine
you know you're finding that we've been
far too trusting of that system of
medicine and and so yeah not only am I
free to practice what I think is good
Madison now um and I can draw from so
many different disciplines and
approaches and mechanisms and many of
which are extremely safe that's also the
problem right
um because if it's really safe and
effective uh they don't want you to know
about it and so it is a very freeing
thing but also I'm in intellectually
free I'm much more inspired and
questioning and open-minded I'm
open-minded to the point I've never been
like literally Brett I mean I hated
vitamins before I would you know why I
hated them and when I say hate that's a
strong word I I was very troubled by the
the billion dollar industry in peddling
vitamins which I didn't think were
really adding to the health of people
and I'm wrong about that actually I'm
not saying all vitamins are necessary
actually I do think they're overused you
know in generally healthy people but I
was sick of reading trials showing that
vitamins were ineffective like the
literature's so full of them I was just
like enough with vitamin can we stop
they don't work they're not good for
anything that's literally what I used to
think and and even around synthetic you
know you know the way alternate you know
the alternative practitioners are
presented to allopas I mean allopaths
are told we we're given this arrogance
and these egos right that like we have
the best science in medicine like a
chiropractor is some lower form of
practitioner or even an osteopath or any
other discipline is less than we are and
actually I'm finding
there's another one I actually think the
opposite is true some of the doctors
that I'm not working with and learning
from are unbelievably effective at
helping people preserve their health
treating illness in really safe ways
using combinations of therapies I I
would I would have thought were
uncredible before and
um I hope I hope my transformation
happens to a lot more because like like
we said before in this country is going
to need a lot more but we need this
system of Science and medical Sciences
is broken it's been captured and um
we need to free more Physicians from
that system they have to know they have
to be freed from that system and we have
to preserve
I think you know I'm I don't want to get
really dark here but we do have to
preserve Private Practice
because Brett you know if that system
that you described right like what is
your prediction if suddenly people flee
the system and go into private practice
and and start doing things like I'm
doing oh goodness what's the reaction
there how is the system going to correct
that
uh you know you you and I are both uh
liberals and
three years ago
I thought Single Payer was a great idea
I wrote a thesis in graduate school
basically describing Medicare for all
that's literally what I wrote at the end
of my master's degree in public health
and when I it pains me to think about it
it's
troubling because I mean I'm not even
sure
I think some of my listeners are going
to have to listen very carefully to what
I have to say
I am terrified of things like
single-payer at this point yes because I
understand the
degree of capture that we face and the
degree of power that that gives uh
entities that are not interested in your
health over the uh the practitioners
doesn't mean that there is not you know
were we to be able to rescue our
governmental structure or build a
different one that was resistant to
capture
it doesn't mean there wouldn't be value
in thinking about whether or not a
single-payer system worked better than
what we've got but
given the level of capture I'm
interested in uh changing the balance of
power and having it be placed back in
the hands of doctors who can handle it
um and I now realize that all sorts of
things you know
um
Insurance of any kind whether it be a
governmental program or private
the idea of standard of care right all
of these things become weaponizable yes
and the degree to which whatever it is
that's doing the weaponizing is
apparently
comfortable with the atrogenic harm yes
is spectacular
so I I want to kind of emphasize
something you said because you're right
I think you use
Single Payer if you look at the
structure and you look at as a system
there are attractions right there are
efficiencies there's some
comprehensiveness to it there's more
inclusive I mean there are real
strengths that would on paper draw you
towards a single parent and that's why I
say it pains me when I think back to
what I wrote when I was 27 years old
because the thing that I didn't
understand was what you talked about
which is the fact that our system has
been captured if you make it
single-payer you're just giving them
more power and control to really it's
actually bad for our health and and I
would also want to make the wider Point
um Brad this is even bigger than
medicine which is one of the lessons
I've learned in covid is the more you
concentrate the power in a single entity
or at a certain level for instance the
federal government or the Executive
Branch the more that's concentrated the
more you put yourself at risk to that
and and that really the answer is
decentralizing if that's the only way to
protect from that overwhelming
concentration of because if you put your
like you put all your eggs in one basket
and that basket gets stolen
you're out of luck right and and you
know and that's that almost has
political implications right so for me
like like I'll give you another thing
that I've I've had to rethink like it's
almost like I've had to rethink how I
understood science society and life and
some of the belief like for instance you
said that we're both liberals so in a
very simplistic way I kind of always
believed in what I thought was good
government I actually thought government
could be good and that it really was
necessary to level the playing field and
I and I and I sort of look back at some
of the major policy uh improvements of
last century and you know where you
didn't have such a polarized society and
all that I mean I thought government did
some really important things last
century and and I still believed I had a
concept that that could still be
possible but now I've had to almost
rethink my political philosophy because
now
governing is not government anymore
right it's it's it's really controlled
by corporations and so
so you know and and so this and I I
don't know if if you want to go
political here but what's interesting to
me so like you use the example of those
doctors still in the system they don't
know how they're being constrained they
don't know how their thoughts and the
information is being censored
um I had a recent experience where um
some in-laws came over and um I have a
couple in-laws who are like you know
Die Hard liberals and they knew that I
was living they you know they're very
upset that I hang out with Ron Johnson
okay so like that that kind of liberal
right and and
um you know as we were I was having this
talk discussion them I'm listening to
them talk and I realized
that I'm talking to someone who doesn't
understand that the government's been
captured and they were really highly
supportive of the administration and the
government and it was weird it's like
you know I used to believe like you but
I can't anymore and I feel like now
actually liberals have now they're not
liberal anymore they've literally
supporting corporations
strange they are captured
in a way rather like doctors who don't
realize that they've been captured yes
right and you know the there's no
there's no more dangerous belief than
blue no matter who
yes right you're placing trust in a
system
that has zero claim to be trustworthy
yes correct none
so anyway I um
glad you raised this it uh it it brings
us quite naturally to uh to uh the
Odyssey which is a little little book in
the end of the Odyssey um uh Odysseus
returns to the manor
you will recall and um he uh he goes
into the manor you know dressed in an
inconspicuous I think like a vagrant and
strings the bow and lays waste to the
captors of the manor and I think the
point is this is this is not a liberal
or conservative point this is a
patriotic Point yes it is the moment at
which
um Odysseus needs to string the bow and
retake the manner so that we can have
something like good governance right
um many of us have
received an incredible education
uh inadvertently and very painfully
during covid at what has actually
um
dressed itself as if it was our
government but is actually acting
against our interests yeah and it is
that moment so sorry for the digression
no but I want to say one more thing on
that digression because you talk about
the manner and stringing the bow
um
you know
I have to say so like my confusion and
my stances on my thoughts towards
government and politics you know have
also been disrupted with this pandemic
and learning what I've learned but you
know what was really kind of a very warm
experience for me and I'm just going to
speak plainly about it but you know I I
went to Bobby Kennedy's opening you know
the opening of his campaign and that
speech that speech brat I mean
wow I feel like I'm gonna get tears
literally I'm not really emotional man
because I listen to that guy and I just
was like
I
I was so drawn to his message and his
vision and his Solutions like he gets it
he gets it in in a way that's so deep
and he's so pragmatic and studied and
like
I was extremely moved he reminded me
what I believed in you know he reminded
me like where I came from and what I
really think is true and right and
I I found it very inspirational and very
hopeful I hadn't had hope like that I
haven't felt true hope I felt a lot of
Despair to be on and spread I I'm kind
of down about a lot of stuff because
this war has been hard and it's yeah and
I see so much damage and destruction and
it's getting worse and and I don't know
I don't want to make this about Bobby
but I do want to say that like for me
personally it was a very um restorative
experience
and so I'm actually thrilled that uh
that you saw that as the right follow-on
point to my bizarre digression into the
Odyssey
because it's exactly what I'm talking
about there you go there you go and not
only is it exactly I've tweeted out
Odysseus 24 a couple times no nobody
knows what the hell right it gets no
traction it doesn't land on anything
that anybody recognizes but this is
exactly what I'm thinking is that
you know
and I don't I don't mean to
synonymize it with Bobby Kennedy but he
is certainly what I see in my mind when
I look at uh Odysseus returning to the
manor and stringing the bow yep right
this is somebody who understood what we
were
who has paid a terrible personal price
and
is in a position because he's so
honorable and thoughtful and
insightful
um
to
to restore
the world that no longer is and I will
also say not only do I find his vision
quite compelling but I am deeply
heartened by
the extent to which it resonates across
ideological lines
right yes he is he is a liberal like you
and I are he's in the exiled from The
Blue Team group of liberals of which
there are quite a number
um
but the degree to which people who see
themselves as part of the red team
can hear what Bobby Kennedy is saying
and resonate with it is very heartening
yes so I'm excited about it too me too
me too for sure
wow um if I can go back you mentioned uh
the vaccine schedule and the
uh explosion in
chronic disease
I also see this the same way I don't
know what the truth is of the vaccine
schedule and its relevance or the
explosion in the vaccine schedule and
its relevance to the explosion in
chronic disease but I do know
that the implication of the explosion in
chronic disease
implicates
environmental exposures yes and for any
of the people who so smugly declare that
it is not the vaccines fine why are you
not obsessed with figuring out what it
is
right because the point is you're
talking about Generations yet unmaimed
who we could save yeah if we can figure
out what it is and if it's not the
vaccine's great let's rule them out and
let's figure out what else is doing it
and let's stop doing it because you're
talking about
crippling people yes
and so anyway I you know but even bigger
I want to make a subtle uh besides the
crippling you know because we were
talking Brett about the
you know like the the system and what
are those incentives like how would that
system behave you know
which is really the opposite of our
health but you know it's creating
literally customers
for life because those are chronic
conditions that they have medicines for
and God and so you know you give someone
let's say chronic severe asthma or
allergies or ADHD or Autism
I mean that that's that's a huge
population of patients that you're
creating over a lifetime and and that's
just disturbing to think about as
anything
it's physiological brand loyalty right
they are creating customers they're
creating captive customers
and it's it's
um
you know look I'm I don't know to what
extent this is a conscious thing that
Pharma does I know that there will be
elements of it that are highly conscious
and there will be other elements where
the system doesn't even understand what
it has evolved to do right it just
enriches people who Advance the ball at
public expense but
um
the net effect
is diabolical diabolical it's diabolical
you're actually talking about not only
just
harming maiming people
you're talking about in many cases
maiming children
yep right and
no healthy Society can tolerate that and
we have tolerated it
too long I want to make a point about
the
the diet about how diabolical is because
here here's another thought I have on is
that
very extent of its evil and Corruption
and really the implications of it how
horrible those consequences are I also
think somehow protects the system in a
way because
Brett to fully conceive of what we're
talking being able to admit into your
mind that there is a system that's being
run
by leaders who know these things and yet
do these things anyway you then have to
be able to countenance or consider the
fact that there are literal sociopaths
running Industries
and and I think you know for some like I
can believe that now because I've seen
that evil play out in covid
I think before I I
think I had a general sense that people
are but I do think the average person is
benevolent and you know is kind and or
capable of it and that I think there are
few that are really capable of of
committing acts and and behaving in a
way where they know that the
consequences of those actions can create
immense amounts of death and disease
um I think those people are few but but
they exist and they can get into power
and they can convince others to do the
same and they they have ways of
rationalizing the psychology I think
there are many people complicit in that
system that don't go home at night I
think they go home at night thinking
they're part of a functioning system
that is directed towards good objectives
and
and and I think that's another lesson
that we've learned that I think I think
for many people like for instance I'll
give you an example I testified in um
the Wisconsin State Legislature
um with a health a medical Freedom group
that was really concerned because the
Wisconsin State Department of Health
wanted to mandate the meningococcal
vaccine as well as the chickenpox
vaccine
um and we can skip the science on how
just insanely
terrible just the science to support
those mandates just on a mandate alone
I'm sorry there's just no I'm done with
many so anyway I was testifying
and luckily for the first time or not
not the first time because Senator
Johnson's committees were friendly to me
but this was a friendly committee they
actually knew my work they knew my
organization and the chairman of the
committee really wanted to hear from me
and the point is this is that they let
me speak quite freely and I I kind of
almost talked a little bit about what
we've talked about in this conversation
I just said like what I've come to learn
in covid and the things that I've
learned and and then I described the
Unholy Alliance that you and I started
you know this podcast with and and when
I when I sketched out that Unholy
Alliance there was this one Democratic
member leading Democratic member and
when it came time for her to ask
questions Brett you could totally see
that I had like you know it was way too
much for her she's like yeah you know Dr
core you're describing this Grand
conspiracy between these and like she
could not get it and what was
interesting is
so and she said so all of these people
you know you're describing so you're
saying all of the doctors and all of the
journalists and you know she she
basically wanted she couldn't understand
she basically she couldn't believe
the system or the world that I was
describing and she couldn't get her head
around and you know I corrected her I
said no
I don't think all those people are evil
and as part of the conspiracy I said
they're victims they're victims of of
that information I said you know because
it isn't that there's all part of us but
the bigger point was that like you know
you have to be able to
you have to be able to I guess accept
the idea that that this kind of behavior
Can Happen and our institutions in
society can behave in this way and I
think for many people they're not ready
to accept that that they're imp even
after covet their implicit faith and
trust in the the pillars and
institutions of society have not been
thoroughly shaken
and or disruptive to the point that it
should be
well you know you raise a very important
point it's one I have learned
to be careful not only in how I speak
about it but how I think about it
and
let me let me convey to you the tool
that I think
does as good a job as of solving this
problem as anything
there are psychopaths out there
and the ones who are both
devoid of moral constraints and
insightful about things the Smart Ones
do tend to ascend to
um
powerful positions yes
and it doesn't take very many of them in
such powerful positions to have a wildly
disproportionate effect yes but the
important part is to realize how much
emergent properties
can
stand in for actual collusion
um
right if you were to
teleport onto this planet during the
height of covid and you were to find
doctors telling patients
don't take Ivermectin
don't consider having it around in case
you're exposed don't
take anything early
should you have symptoms
do
take this experimental therapeutic
irrespective of the accelerated way in
which it was tested the small number of
people on the home it was tested right
if you saw doctor after doctor
dispensing the same advice you could
conclude oh my God these doctors don't
care
about their patients
but you know that's not true
I know you know that those doctors were
in a very an artificially created
impossible bind that they couldn't solve
and many of them did a poor job with the
puzzle they were handed but it wasn't
that these people didn't go into
medicine for the right reasons or were
cryptically sociopathic and correct you
know none of those things were true the
fact is something
rearranged their incentives so they
behaved on behalf of something that was
de facto sociopathic yes and so what I
do what I would encourage you to do and
what I think we need to say to people
like the person who questioned you on
this panel
is
that we don't know
the degree to which there is
conspiratorial action we'd be fools to
think it was Zero
but it could in fact be the minor
fraction
of a system in which people responding
to their incentives do the bidding of
something
evil without being evil themselves and
this is something people have known
right the banality of evil
that concept is about the idea that
normal people who aren't bad can be
dragged into Very Bad Things without the
awareness that that has happened I I
think
your point is really well taken and I I
would say that I agree with it and and
you're right I mean
the banality and good people are capable
of participating in Acts uh either
unknowingly
um that really uh bring about great
great harm and um you know one of the
thoughts I had in listening to what you
just said you know
those doctors right who are put in this
really difficult position
I I would think that there was almost a
psychological incentive
to believe the vaccines were safe and
effective right so so I mean if you want
to start questioning and looking at the
data around vaccines you you're going to
make things quite difficult for yourself
meaning intellectually morally
philosophic right I mean so it's almost
I mean that system that train was
barreling down that track right if you
want to stay on the train you know
I think I think there I think there was
some sort of site you know you you want
to believe that the system is behaving
correctly that the experts are giving
good advice and so
don't question the advice because you're
going to find out stuff about the system
and your role in it that's going to be
very uncomfortable
and I think actually if I look back at
what I saw it matches it matches your
description and it matches the following
pattern
doctors are told
we have safe and effective vaccines
they're the way out of this frightening
pandemic
um
the doctors know
safe and effective can't mean totally
safe
and they're probably not fully effective
but the doctors initially just as you
and I didn't initially see how far off
the portrayed picture was from what
turned out to be
the doctors all privately
said to themselves
you know every vaccine
causes casualties right but it's going
to be a small number relative to the
good that will be done covet is tearing
the world apart and so what they did is
they held their tongue about the
discrepancy between the claim that these
things were totally safe and what they
privately believed about the level of
safety which was tolerably safe
at the point that it became clear
that they were not remotely tolerably
safe and that they were being given to
people who had no reason to be exposed
to any risk at all
they had already
started lying
on behalf of the system they thought
they were telling a white lie yes in
fact they were telling a gargantuan lie
much bigger than they would have
contemplated had they had the full
picture to begin with but at the point
that you've done that at the point that
you've done the bidding of Pharma
he had uh cost to your Patients health
and then you start to get the sense of
what might be lurking in the evidence
the Instinct not to look at it has got
to be quite strong because you don't
want to know what you've been dragged
into there's no question and that also
you know what we just talked about
that really
also explains
the inability to talk about or treat
vaccine injury I mean look look at where
we are with that threat so you have
academic medical centers around the
country many of them created what they
call Long coveted clinics
and they're absolutely useless it's
endless referrals and testing and
unfortunately the the Diagnostics around
um
that guide therapies for these two the
testing is not very helpful but so
patients get a lot of tests a lot of
referrals there's no treatments right
there's no guidelines yet I'm sure
that's a market that they're going to
explore actually I do know that right
because the the 1.2 billion that the
government has already devoted to
research into long covet
um uh they apparently there's five
trials that they've set up only one is
ready to uh enroll they haven't enrolled
the patient yet so there's only one
trial and um wait for it Brett do you
know what they're going to study
I guess we just maybe discovered the
last little piece of my naive tank yeah
but but
specialist intrigue in tree and coveted
vaccine injury
um you know my patients come to me after
journeying through the system and and
you know I would say the climate has
changed but in the beginning those early
vaccine injured what they went through
in terms of gaslighting and abandonment
and outright like I mean I have stories
from my patients where literally when
they tried to talk to the doctor about
the vaccine injury the doctors I think
it created such
like I think it was very disturbing for
doctors because they didn't want to
recognize that now people are showing up
with these severe chronic disabilities
and abilities and and they actively
fought against like I remember one
patient told me a story that when she
was signing out of a doctor's office at
the reception desk the doctor actually
came out there and told the patient you
don't need to schedule the follow-up
essentially telling the patient don't
come back
and and not only that so doctors were
not writing vaccine injury in the chart
for a long time and you remember I mean
the political climate and the
victimization around vaccine I mean that
the height of the Psychopathology around
vaccines was
I mean I will never forget that where we
what was happening in society and now
it's better now it's better now I think
vaccine injury can be discussed from
what I know from doctors on the inside
it is written in charts
um people doctors are now talking to
patients a little bit more now they
don't know how to treat it
um you know because again that that's
the other consequence Brad you know we
talked about autonomy and that tight
control and coercion
um it's really scary because this novel
disease of long covet and vaccine injury
is really complex there's a number of
pathophysiologic mechanisms there's a
whole host of potential therapies and I
am learning as I go I'm my protocol is
ever shifting and how I approach these
patients but picture a doctor in the
system right now who employed by some
major health system who a vaccine
injured patient comes maybe they know
our work you know and and our protocol
in the flccc website
um
and let's say they want to try to employ
you know they have a patient before them
who's suffering and they're like you
know well there's this group who's done
this work and they've put out this this
guide and maybe we can try a few things
like that for instance
I ever met in his Pro is the most
effective drug I've found in those two
Center doesn't work for everybody and in
some people the the benefits are modest
um but far and away it's the most
successful
um I would say 70 of my patients with
long covet and vaccine injury
um are Ivermectin responders I'd say 70.
and again the responses vary but that
that's the other implication that's the
other consequences of of that change to
the system is those doctors are waiting
for a guideline they're waiting for a
society and by the way there's no
Society statements there's no review
papers on vaccine it's literally
verboten the only people talking about
are like organizations like myself and
and similar organizations and so you
know the the implications are you know
but we were talking about like the
psychology of the doctor and I think
that fueled the the literally and I
heard you know descriptions of you could
see doctors who were having a really
tough time in incontinencing and and
being able to
see a vaccine per injured person for
what they were which is they were a
consequence of that same doctor's
behaviors
well
um
that's certainly true
the
I'm struggling there's a couple
directions to go from here Heather and I
did an episode a couple weeks back
in which we actually looked at the
Nuremberg code itself
and found that the coveted response
appears to have violated not just
informed consent a double violation
because people were ill-informed as a
result of propaganda and they were
mandated and coerced so it wasn't
consent
but every single subprovision
seems to have been violated too and not
in an in obvious way it's glaring when
you look at it
and so
the
one of the provisions involves
mental anguish
and I I must say that there are a lot of
facts
if you paid attention to how the
pandemic unfolded in the public health
response and the coup against medicine
and all of these things there are these
anomalies right just very strange facts
that are very hard to reconcile with any
normal process
the most glaring of them I think the one
that I Stumble over uh
most forcefully is
the gaslighting of the vaccine injured
because
these people without exception
are people who did what they were told
they were supposed to do
and so the idea that if you were telling
people you're morally bad if you don't
follow our advice and you don't get
yourself so-called vaccinated with these
so-called vaccines
and then somebody gets hurt even if the
vaccines had turned out to be
very
safe
which they did not but if they had and
these injuries were vanishingly rare
we should be dealing with the people who
have these injuries with nothing but
compassion right right these were people
who were trying to do the right thing
you can't you know the idea that these
are anti-vaxxers is laughable these are
people who got hurt because they took
the vaccine
and whatever to the extent that the
argument was
that the vaccines are our Collective
responsibility in order to get us out of
covid which was nonsense from the get-go
because they didn't block transmission
or contraction and therefore couldn't be
an effective tool against the pandemic
but to the extent that people accepted
the argument that what they were doing
was taking a small risk on behalf of the
team
it is then our Collective responsibility
to take as good care of them as can be
done
in light of the fact that they got on
luck
that you right that would be I think
that situation is correct I think that
would have been the what you would think
is the Humane and ethical and
appropriate response of a physician to
an unfortunate rare you know supposedly
rare but let me ask you a question so
what do you
so maybe I'm interrupting so that you're
saying that would have been the correct
and Humane response
absolutely natural consequence of the
[__] argument that was fed to us or
rammed down our throats right that you
have an obligation to get these things
as a member of the team
right so that means that to the extent
that Our obligation as members of the
team came up bad for a small number of
people because of bad luck then those
harms belong to all of us right but let
me ask you a question Brett the fact is
you're you just use the hypothetical
example of if they had been safe and
just leaving a very tiny number but the
reality was that those numbers are
massive
so the fact that that's not what
happened do you think it was the massive
numbers that that somehow influenced the
the the the treatment and and how they
were treated by doctors nope I think
that we are again Downstream of an
industrial strength propaganda campaign
whose purpose is not anybody's
well-being
it is the
I don't know the uh shareholder value of
the corporations that produce these
things and any level of propaganda and
lying and Distortion that enhances the
position of these corporations
uh is tolerable to them for some reason
but I guess my point is an average
person who bought the story
ought to now look
at the way the vaccine injured have been
treated and that ought to be enough to
wake them up completely right if you are
somebody who said oh these vaccines are
safe what does that mean perfectly safe
yes perfectly safe well
everybody knows they weren't perfectly
safe yeah so that means there are some
vaccine injured people where is the
place where these people are being
compassionately embraced by the system
where we are trying to understand these
very rare injuries and what might be
done to alleviate them doesn't exist why
because what exists in its place is
a propaganda campaign of its own that
adds insult to injuries you are
psychologically torturing these injured
people who were trying to do their part
on behalf of a team because you told
them that's what they had to do
so my point is that is that is a sick
system that would tell people this was
their obligation as a member of a team
and then when it didn't work out
pretends that they're not sick
right it's diabolical it's diaper and
you know one of the phrases I keep using
is it just seems like the world has gone
mad and and it's I want to refer that
you know
the worldwide man and coven all these
behaviors that we're talking about and I
agree with you I I attribute the madness
that has descended upon all this is from
unrelenting propaganda and censorship
we've been sickened by the
information that that we need in order
to to live and live correctly and and in
harmony right and and yet we're pro the
information is in Poison we started
talking like at the level of the
journals and all of this and you know
that you brought up another point which
is the you know it was so bad the
propaganda and censorship supporting
this vaccine campaign was so horrible
and Powerful that
you saw this phenomenon because you kind
of touched on it where
anyone close to the unvaccinated I would
call them vaccine adjacent
were attacked and the one example are
people who got vaccinated and tried to
speak up about their injuries they were
literally immediately lumped in with the
you know the ire and attacks were
directed at them and you know for me one
of the most memorable and heartbreaking
examples I don't know you've heard of
this case but there was a a professional
mountain bike racer um Kyle I can't
remember his last name but
he filmed himself in his car one day
talking about how his career was over he
was really sick and he was crying
because
he had been trying to talk about his
injury not only for help but also I
guess to tell others and he couldn't
believe the amount of people attacking
him and the amount of anger and ferocity
directed at him for him just trying to
talk about his experience and you know
that's how bad that got
you know any you know people who got
vaccinated were being attacked
well it's
I have uh become somewhat Infamous for
the catchphrase it's worse than that
but it's worse than that because
on the one hand you've got this mountain
biker and I I don't remember his name
but I do remember the case
who
speaks out about just a fact of his life
he was a mountain biker now what is he
right he doesn't know he's
understandably broken up about that and
what's more you know this has
implications for his longevity and you
know it's it's a tragic case and it's it
is an Exemplar of a pattern that is much
more widespread but the other thing you
probably saw RAV Aurora's recent piece
about a
um
a journalist I think an editor
at a publication and the publication was
decidedly uh enthusiastic about vaccines
and mandates
and the
uh the editor
had a severe
vaccine injury an immediate one right
and these things get much more difficult
for us to Grapple with when they're
delayed right a delayed cancer for
example
the room to pretend that it's not
Downstream or the room for there to be
statistical noise or whatever but this
was a case where somebody had a uh an
immediate and intense
uh adverse event
um that was cardiac in nature it was
myocarditis I believe and
anyway the point is that person has
apparently still not come forward and
the publication that they worked for
hasn't acknowledged
that it was championing these vaccines
and then right on their doorstep
had an event that ought to have caused
them to think hey wait a minute that
seems pretty unlikely if these events
are vanishingly rare that one of our own
would have had it maybe we should look
into how widespread they are so anyway
my point is
our impression in the public of how
common these events are
is Downstream of a campaign to punish
and intimidate people who've had these
events so that they will talk about them
as little as possible or not at all
which leaves the false impression that
they were much safer than they actually
were yeah I mean I also think Brett you
know when you bring up the example of
that editor in that outlet or whatever
news source that was
um
you know not talking about it that that
seems very governmental and Military
censor I mean it seems like everyone got
the memo in the media Thou shalt not
speak ill of these vaccines I mean with
very few exceptions uh most media
sources never even
brought up the possibility that these
vaccines weren't safe and and you know
the the most
the most absurd and dystopian are the
thousands and thousands of reports of
young people dropping dead
athletes
broadcasters on television comedians on
stage I mean all walks of life many
times caught on camera young healthy
people out doing like once you're
outside doing an activity by the way
it's a pretty good comment on your
underlying health okay like I mean sick
people are not doing what these people
do particularly athletes and so you have
these and then the ages you know I am an
expert in sudden cardiac death it has an
ICU specialist that was one of the the
patient populations I had to take care
of those that survived CPR and it's
it's it's so incredibly rare for young
people to drop dead
and you have Legions of newspaper
reports report after report after report
after report of no anteceding event and
the vaccine is never mentioned never
once mentioned as a possibility
and the consistency in in the
consistency under which that is true you
know and I used to read those reports I
literally would skim them to see if the
journalist writing about this tragic and
Unexpected death of a young for a high
schooler you know whatever the case is
you know
I was just waiting to see if
they would just you know unclear cause
maybe you know could it be the vaccines
or there's no mention in any of those
articles that's a vaccine it's just a
normal rare occurrence
now
I'm glad you bring this up
uh I've done a lot of thinking about it
the problem here I believe is also
obviously Downstream of the same
propaganda campaign we've been talking
about yeah
the problem is these events are
extremely rare
naturally
the vigilance about finding these events
and pointing to them is now unusually
high
right so to the extent that this happens
very rarely and you generally don't hear
about it but now it broadcasts an
individual anomalous death broadcast to
a much wider audience one has to ask the
question
is what I'm seeing an artifact of
sampling a much larger population
now I don't believe it could be and you
as an ICU specialist
are in a much better position to say
that you believe the level of this is
unusual however here's where I think
this goes
we have to be cautious because there
will be deaths
that we hear about that contribute to
our sense that vaccines have created a
lot of injuries in young people that
actually are just anomalies they may be
some other environment environmental
exposure to something novel but maybe
it's not the vaccine
but here's here's the the important
point
this isn't a tough question to study no
right this is what science does
and if we were really interested in the
question of well
is there an anomalous pattern of young
people dropping dead there is
if there's that pattern and it is
Downstream of the vaccines we can find
out if we want to and what we seem to be
doing is avoiding finding out that's
absolutely correct but let me speak to
that Brad because in in my mind
that question has been soundly answered
with data and interestingly or maybe
unsurprisingly it doesn't come out of
the medical sciences that data that data
is coming out of the life insurance
industry
and Ed dowd's work on this with his team
I mean when you hear these numbers I
mean and and how that story broke and
how that data came out was really
interesting you know there was a
newspaper article I can't time it it
might it's probably over a year ago
where a CEO of a life insurance company
won America was apparently talking to a
chamber of commerce like it was just a
meeting at a Chamber of Commerce and he
lets it slip that they saw I think it
was either 38 or 40 percent rise in
death claims in the age group from 18 to
64.
from 2020 to 2021 so in one year and he
said in that same meeting that in his
business a 10 rise in mortality in that
age group from one year to the next
would be a statistically a one in two
hundred year event that's how rare 10 is
and here he is
telling a group of folks that this
hundred billion dollar million dollar
company is saw 38 rise and the timing of
the rise
perfectly matches the vaccine rolled out
um that you know the data showing how
many people have law we've lost from the
workforce actually from Death is truly
alarming
and so it's like we already know I'm
Sorry Brad I mean for me those vaccines
are a humanitarian catastrophe they've
caused hundreds of thousands of deaths
and you're right though we we don't
no one's talking about it
well look I don't disagree with you
about what the most parsimonious
interpretation of the evidence that I've
seen is I think it's quite clear but the
point I'm trying to make is to the
extent there are many people out there
who still don't believe there is a
pattern there ought to be an obsession
with doing the most
deliberate and careful study possible to
discover the nature of that pattern
right we're still giving these shots to
people
I can't understand that we're still
giving these shots to young people right
that couldn't be a more medically
irresponsible thing to do if it tried
healthy young people
why would you give them a shot for a
disease that does not put them at
substantial risk
so anyway I'm not doubting yeah I'm not
doubting the evidence from the insurance
industry what I'm doubting is our
ability
to look at the reports of sudden death
in people and to know the contribution
of vaccines versus the contribution of
the level of Interest yeah and I
appreciate that point I mean that you're
right anybody should be asking the
question
yep we should be asking a question and
like we ask lots of questions in science
we have ways of answering it and there's
a process in which to do it and it's not
being done we have entire institutions
full of people who trained to be able to
answer such questions and we are not
pointing them at this one nope which is
shocking nope
all right so I want to uh we're gonna
wrap up here soon
I have two points I want to get on the
table and get your reaction to before we
do that great
one of them is just an interesting
pattern okay you now find yourself in
private practice you were a
a hospital a teaching Hospital doc an
academic you now find yourself in
private practice strangely liberated to
think about therapy as you wouldn't have
considered before to retrain yourself
free from the influence of
Administrators and
standards and all of that which it turns
out we're much more destructive than you
had known that's fascinating
Heather and I have seen the same pattern
as
um
Outsiders to Academia now free to think
I mean we thought independently before
and that's probably why we got kicked
out but um but nonetheless now uh the
thing that threatens us are you know
Anonymous Tech Giants that don't like us
speaking out of turn because it's very
inconvenient to have evolutionary
biology phds
uh calling [__] on epidemiologists
and vaccinologists right inconvenience
so you know Tech is now trying to exert
its influence but nonetheless
outside of the system we have a degree
of Freedom that is uh anomalous
you mentioned at the top of the podcast
that
um our mainstream media sources are
owned by a tiny number of Corporations
which artificially synchronizes their
viewpoint on the other hand
their ability to Garner audience has
plummeted and that ought hasn't gone
away it's migrated to this unregulated
uh low production value landscape
of podcasts and man caves and you know
uh you know doing your own news
broadcast from your living room or
whatever and the point is that's not
really the right place to be doing it
much as the right place for you to be
doing what you do Doc is in a hospital
in which you know yeah the the system
and the equipment and all of that is
already there and and the system for
getting it paid for and all is built the
right place to study science and to talk
about it is not podcasts universities
and they exist but we're outside of them
anyway my point is
the structures are now a good proxy for
the corruption yeah right you can look
at the University buildings and think oh
they're very pretty it's interesting
that science doesn't work in there
anymore right you can go to CNN and you
can say oh that looks like a a humming
Newsroom there that looks like a great
place for them to figure out what the
hell is going on and to tell the public
but that's not what they do no right you
know that is more likely to happen uh
you know in Joe Rogan's Studio yep so
anyway everybody's doing the job that
they're supposed to be doing to the
extent that those of us who care about
these jobs are still doing them we're
doing them in places that don't make
sense right we've been it's like a whole
civilization in Exile
right where yes uh good point
yeah and it's uh anyway I I guess it
just it's hopeful to me because the
point is it isn't like they snuffed us
out they just
uh sent us free yeah and we're supposed
to Source our own equipment yeah no I I
agree with that I mean um I've sometimes
made jokes that have you know I've been
excommunicated from medicine
um and um and you're right we are sort
of Exiles but you know it's an
interesting dynamic because our numbers
are growing you know I mean you and I
fit I mean you before me I mean your
career your academic career literally
ended and you were excommunicated and
yeah so we really were exiled but I
think that the audience the the average
citizen you know they are coming to to
listen more to people like you and me
and you know
yeah it's it's
I I have hope because that's the answer
right and I like I love that you just
said like this the structures are
synonymous with the or emblematic of the
corruption right I mean you look at a
university you look at a newsroom like
that's literally a propaganda uh you
know headquarters that's where they
create the day's narratives right and so
and and and for people to believe in
those structures and institutions
um
it gives me hope
because really when the system's been
captured we need a parallel system and
and that's why we kind of touched on the
we want Private Practice to continue and
we we need Freedom we need we need a
space to freely discuss things and you
need people who are free to
tell the news like it really is you know
and what's really happening in the world
and and um
I'm happy to see that's happening
yeah I think uh and maybe we'll just
leave it here but I think the message of
it is
the
power
that was brought to bear to Stamp Out
our ability to do a scientific analysis
to
reach an audience and tell them what we
thought to practice
responsible medicine to respond to
emerging patterns and sort through them
the power that was brought to bear was
absolutely
industrial strength military grade it
was ferocious
and the degree to which it failed to
Stamp Out the actual discussion
uh is I think remarkable
and quite hopeful in other words I do
think the small
collection of dissidents
that did find their way to speak out
about the absurdity of our coveted
response
upended the negative The Narrative and
and most
you know most people are not awake right
but many people are at least somewhat
awake yeah and that is
that's a very hopeful sign it's very
hard to Stamp Out apparently and
hopefully only more we will see more
wake up over time yeah my the point I
would add to that is
you're right I mean that industrial
strength and trying to Snuff it out they
did not succeed number one and I think
the brazenness and overreach of their
attempts
um might even turn in backfire on them
because of the amount of people that
they've awakened I mean Brett I don't
know that I would have woken up if they
hadn't done this much you know so much
Breeze and departures from science and
pragmatism
that that had to make me question why is
this happening who is doing this and why
would they possibly do this I mean that
that will that woke me up and and I and
so many people and so I I think armed
with that new knowledge it'd be
interesting to see where the future is
yep I agree with you and I think
everybody has that moment
where they see something that
they just can't unsee yeah and for many
of us it was covid yep and uh our you
know our numbers are growing and I think
it's time to string the bow yes love it
great way to agree way to end but Brett
great way to all right uh Dr Pierre
Corey
um it has been a real pleasure
your book is it it is available already
yeah it's in bookstores and on Amazon
and I just heard from a friend that they
went to buy a book and it was sold out
they're sold out that Santa Barbara saws
pretty happy to hear that news that's
great news uh the title of the book
is the war on Ivermectin yes the war on
Ivermectin
um for people and there will be many who
have heard you on Dark Horse and realize
that they might need your help for
either long covered or a vaccine injury
or just simply to get
medical care that is out from under the
thumb of Pharma and fouching
um where do they find you yeah we'd also
take care of general medicine patients
you know we're happy to support you with
uh non-conflicted guidance and that's it
uh the easiest is Dr Pierre corey.com Dr
pierrecory.com
um or just look up my name with the
Leading Edge Clinic if you just look up
my name it's gonna be hard to find like
because there's a lot of other stuff
that comes up Fred
yeah there's a lot of stuff that comes
up and I must say I have Googled uh your
name and Uh something's got its thumb on
the scales so anyway yeah
um the uh the URL was Dr
k-o-r-y No that
d-r-p-i-e-r-r-e-k-o-r-y.com so Dr
pierrecordy.com Dr pierrecory.com all
right the war on IRA mechan this has
been an excellent conversation I'm
already looking forward to our next one
uh
best of luck with the book and um
anyway thank you for uh for doing this
right all I can say is you know thank
you for your support
for your audience I I love the
conversation and
and really thank you for your
Brotherhood in in this journey it's been
um
it's been rough
yeah it has been rough well uh it's been
an honor to fight shoulder shoulder
definitely definitely
thanks
ciao ciao
[Music]